the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the rapid portion ended in dramatic
fashion at the super united rapid and
blitz in zagreb croatia players
scrambled to gain crucial points before
the non-stop adrenaline rush of blitz
the legendary magnus carlson looked to
be rounding into form defeating dutch
front-runner jordan van forest getting
his first win since round two however
despite suffering the early loss to the
reigning world champion van forest
rebounded to take down the clear leader
alareza farouja to claim pole position
in the event but it's not over yet with
plenty of blitz action on the way day
four of incredible chess coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to day four of the grand chess
tour behind me the statue of the first
ruler of croatia king tommy slap who'll
find themselves king on our first day of
blitz let's find out with our
commentators miro yasser and christian
hello everyone welcome to our live
coverage of the grand chess tour from
zagreb croatia we are in saint louis
missouri and we're getting ready for a
day of blitz and what action we have for
you nine rounds each day of this weekend
miro hello lovely to see you uh your
thoughts about blitz baby okay blitz is
coming in my eyes of course are only
jordan one forest and nobody let's be
fair nobody expected him to perform that
well absolutely uh nobody including
himself right and as we all know chess
players have a special way of trash
talking which is untight trash talking
and if a guy says and that's exactly
what he said in an interview if the guy
says i'm bad at blitz that implies he is
damn good so i'm really working really
looking at him he's a dangerous man well
then having said that let's take a look
at our standings and tell me who's on
top yeah so it's jordan 1 for rest with
12 points and closely followed by a trio
of magnus carlson alireza perugia and
wesley saw all three being an excellent
blitz players right wesley saw and wait
a sec and maximize
those are in the striking zone also
known for their blitz skills absolutely
absolutely and our format as well as our
schedule for this weekend
yeah so today we have nine rounds of
blitz around robin full tournament
played in one day and the same gonna
happen on sunday with colors reversed
super
yeah every 30 minutes the next round is
going to start the game is played with
five minutes for each players plus two
seconds increment from one no draws
whatsoever no draws please and yeah and
a usual finally usual chess uh scoring
system works so one point will win half
a point for a draw nice and uh as always
we so happy to have christian and studio
good to see you my friend who are
the best blitzers in the world
good to see you guys and welcome
everybody to day four this is it it
blitz time baby and the action is
getting faster and more furious but
let's take a look as we enter this
competition where they stand in terms of
world blitz rankings and of course one
name that everybody knows about is
hikaru nakamura the fastest and best
chess player bliss chess player in the
world standing at 28.50 that's an
astronomical ranking but one player that
we know so well and we have in this
tournament is the world champion he
stands at a disappointing for him for
his standards fourth in the world 28 35
he will definitely be looking to make
some waves and gain some rating points
ali reza firusha the young phenom from
france stands in ninth in the world at
27 91 this is just an incredible ranking
for such a young player maxine vascular
graph his compatriot stands at 11th in
the world 27 84 but we know mvl is a
blitz specialist for sure chakriyama
medyarov going into the rapid rankings
he was under 2700 but in the blitz
section he's 13th in the world with 27
78 and he will definitely be looking to
try to improve his standing wesley so
the american is 14th in the world at 27
63 and only one point behind the leader
going into the blitz section yana
pomnyashi the challenger the former
challenger and right now the participant
in the world championship title is 19th
in the world 2740 and lanier dominguez
24th in the world and one player that we
don't even have in this graphic because
actually his rating is around
2609 in the blitz section is the leader
of the event that is jordan van forest
who has been having an amazing time so
far in zagreb but today he's starting
off the blitz section against a big
clash against magnus carlsen his former
boss these players have trained with
each other in preparation for a magnus's
match against jan nepomnyashi last
november this one is definitely going to
be the key match-up of round one for us
and we also have our friends in zagreb
anastasia and alejandro guys how's the
how's the atmosphere there
thank you christian the atmosphere here
is absolutely electric everybody's
excited for the blitz of course it's a
weekend so people are going to be here
by frost
while we're
some technical excuse me unexpectedly
some technical problems mural uh we know
one key match-up as uh christian said
let's take a look at all the pairings
for this first round of blitz yep
well regrettably
yes it's not that easy to pick one pair
and say okay that's that's the main
match-up because every pairing that's
someone who is a blitz specialist so we
have mvl frenchmen with three names
against saric we have nepo and dominguez
let's not forget dominguez was a
well-blitz champion as well
uh mommy arrow against wesley saw fear
roja of course young gun against
vaseline topolov and the game will be a
key match yeah the game will be
following closely is of course carlson
and one for rest right well we can
absolutely guarantee you that when we do
get our sock repeat up again we will uh
jump to that but i wanted to say this is
kind of funny that yesterday uh jordan
van fors played with magnus in the the
last three games of the rapid and
instantly
will he get his revenge i mean and
here he is uh jordan then forest uh
leading our tournament as he said it's a
surreal experience very young 23 years
of age but really an incredibly strong
player as he's entering the hall
and and might get more attention why
none of them or at least not to my eyes
are wearing suits because they have to
be fast exactly and they cannot have any
long-sleeve garment on them that will
impede their movement exactly this is
exactly why we see them wearing t-shirts
or like
all those types of shirts
absolutely
very comfortable setting for jordan van
forest
and actually
this guy just simply impresses me with
his attitude
as well yesterday after his loss against
magnus carlsen he gave an interview to
our colleague anastasia and he was very
happy about just being there and having
this experience playing against the best
chess players in the world and after
that we know what happened he went on to
win a dominant game against ali reza
faruja in the last round definitely a
very good attitude for this young man
definitely and they're going to be
competing as there we see napo versus
lanier getting ready uh for the start of
the first round but
they're fighting for a lot of money 175
000 in fact
and the prize fund is distributed as
follows
yeah so 40k goes to the winner of the
tournament with second prize being 30k
25 000 for the third place and so on and
so on and gct points are important as
well because yeah you collect them
through the tour and
if you've managed to collect the most
you're getting a nice bonus of 100 000
absolutely a very nice uh bonus indeed
and there we saw
i was going to say at the playing hall
the people getting seated in their seats
and this looked like a wonderful stage i
must say that as a chess grandmaster i
always loved it when i came into a full
hall and as i understand it in croatia
the your grandmasters are being asked
for lots and lots of signatures uh did
you ever get uh that kind of uh thing
christian where you're being hunted for
your autograph uh not so much
not so much i had a few uh good
tournaments in which obviously i was uh
asked for uh autographs but obviously
i'm not one of the 2800 level players
these elite level players but i was um
in
poland in warsaw and after every single
day there was a pack of 100 maybe 200 of
players sorry
spectators waiting for the players to
come out of the playing hall and get
interviews and the players were just
trying to escape as fast as possible it
was quite funny how about yourself yes
sir oh yeah i uh
former yugoslavia former soviet union
those were the events where
you were surrounded by crowds and you
weren't going nowhere until you had
signed at least 30 autographs and
i kind of liked it but at the same time
like you said i was below you like it up
to a point up to a point up to a point
especially if you've uh had a rough day
at the office and you lost a lot of
games in a row and then you have to sign
30 autographs some of these players you
know they just try to escape as fast as
possible and there you see the hardy
hand clasp
but
where is our world champion he is
missing in action and by the way
this is once again five plus two i don't
know if they've started his clock
and here he goes he's russell
get to the playing oh
uh
i think magnus was late in one game he
was two and he was a little frustrated
it seemed like maybe it wasn't his fault
but maybe he had difficulties getting
into the playing hall but here he goes
adjusting all of his pieces by the way
before playing one e4 with a little
flourish he was against ivan saric in
the last round and just to inform our
audience what we're going to attempt to
do is going to focus on one game per
round
if the game turns out to be a dud we
have a plan b we'll go to that uh
game very quickly uh but for the moment
our
well
mirror it has to be this game i mean
uh jordan uh leading the tournament
playing against the world champion uh
shall i ask any predictions
well it happened very quickly already
this berlin
yeah predictions no no no predictions
for i meant the opening uh but it
happened so fast
you didn't even have a chance to say oh
it will be the d3 bishop takes c6
uh berlin with h2h3 h7 h6 knight d2 i
think he's on the board he's
hinting that he wants to go potentially
to c4 try target oops e5 pawn or b3
exactly
bishop the ship statistician c6 now you
have no reason to go to be based on
knight c4 perhaps exactly
and now we expect castle
um from the young man even though castle
with the pawn already on h6 is that
dangerous does that allow me to get that
like short castle you might run into
some sort of g4 g4 yeah yeah
you're encouraging it to say yeah and
the knight on c4 will not exchange for
the bishop but go to e3 and maybe jump
try to jump to f5 so you have to be
careful exactly so 97 hinting at the
fact that well he's just going to wait
and
uh match white as soon as white castles
black castles uh
maybe the desirable knight b6
uh you of course always have to be
watchful that the knight doesn't land on
a5 where it's actually more useful
yeah well there is another route for
this night that you go to f8 right and
then depending on what white does
sometimes you end up on g6 and then
looking at the f4 square or even e6
right and we'll see in the vacuum i
would argue that e6 is the best square
right yes of course you you should be
watching what white's doing yeah and
what is white doing why does castle
count
okay uh a clear sign that that jordan
made the right choice not the castle
is short and walk into g4 okay
he's setting up for a long castle as
well yeah bishop a6 trying to encourage
magnus to but
yeah that's okay
that's weird
maybe the other thing that he does with
bishop a6 he's kind of stopping d4 or
postponing d4 for quite some time you
know knight e3 trying to go to f5 g7 gc
simply restricting the knight exactly
and now this opens up the question do i
have some knight to g4 ideas to soften
up the dark squares around the king side
yeah sure but
black has already decided that his
king's going to be perfectly safe on the
queen side so move like knight a knight
g4
encouraging h5
would be bad news if the king was there
not so bad news
the king on the other side bishop c3 by
the way this bishop on a6 is very
annoying the two breaks in the position
are f4 as well as d4
and
it's going to be very hard to get in d4
with the queen on e2 very quickly played
with knight d2 i must say
to my eyes the world champion has gotten
nothing out of the opening yeah knight
c5 and knight to
pardon me knight to c5 threatening like
94
with the idea of knight to e6 looks like
black is perfectly
well yeah he did play it not not only
equalized
i start to prefer
i start to prefer black's position with
the two bishops in control over the d4
square
okay so knight c4
the one thing i would be careful of is
that this knight captures with check
right
so whenever the guy tries
when he tries to sneak it in fortunately
for the moment the knight on c5 protects
it yeah protect the bishop but it's it's
one of the perhaps it's time to get out
of the way king b8 exactly i like that
he decides against it he played instead
so did he play i think he played
five just like we didn't get it
registered yet no no wait
yeah
no g5 would not
it didn't make any sense no f7 f6
shoring up the pawn again
white's brakes are
f4 and d4
so anticipation of the brake
uh f6 is re-fortified but now that you
played f6 and your g6 square is a little
bit tender i can potentially go rook h3
rook g3 or
set up what the g4 break and try to
focus on the g6 he's about to play 96 is
uh knight day four knight a4 interesting
it's a bit more aggressive than that
we're not looking at this direction not
at all um
i'm not a big fan of that i would i
would love to anchor my 96
a totally different approach right
you're a little bit off right this night
before
unless you'd be able to prove tactically
that well it has a purpose there yeah
otherwise it just just does nothing okay
now again i think that you have to prep
f4
looks like rook f1 yeah ruka fun doesn't
seem to be
a bad move
well again it's like group e1
interestingly
so maybe you put a yeah maybe you put a
rook rooks in the center and then queen
f1 and then eventually whenever we play
a four we played with great effect
exactly exactly exactly
the time situation well slightly but
only slightly more time for one for rest
right well by the way i expect some
people to lose on time here
you know we only saw one loss on time in
the whole
rapid event and that was actually magnus
yes exactly i wanted to say the world
championship
uh mismanaging his clock that's a little
embarrassing and here's the opportunity
you've got to play f4 at some point you
have to go f4 there's no other way
exactly you had to
to do something yeah he goes he does and
i'm
not sure that jordan
has positioned his knight f5 is a very
big
threat right
he captured with the queen yeah he
i would eat no i think he took it with
the pawn
whoa if he takes with the pipe
then i was going to say
if he takes with a pawn then f5 is a
threat positionally speaking that's the
big threat in the position that's why he
played f5 black plays f5 yeah
i was thinking of suggesting
whoa yeah
first of all you give up the square
second of all how do we meet takes and
queen h3 that's a very good question or
queen f3 takes actually takes in queen
f3 perhaps he's not worried about that
now for example if you go queen to h3
maybe he's going to try to set up an
attack on b2 with queen to have sex
that's what magnus does he captures on
f5
so now knight will find a very good
position on e5 here right and then queen
f3 or queen eight tree i think one of
those weak poles if i'm going to go
knight e5 i'm going to put my queen on
f3 for sure because i'd love
to tickle this pawn on c6 so it takes
takes
queen f3 with the
nice idea e3 is magnus's choice kicking
out the knight a little bit surprising
unless he had seen something like
forcing because the knight only 4 was
not doing all that much yeah i think he
was uh afraid of queen to f6 and ideas
it's something forcing really that he's
going for
but can black capture on g4 i would be i
would be inclined to try to do that to
be honest because i feel like if i start
going back i'll i might never stop
right there please to change the game
i would actually start thinking about
knight to e4 in this position knight e4
ah so that when you but isn't your night
knight e4 might be a very clever move by
the way
the knight g4 very surprising move to my
eyes queen f3
in knight e5
and by the way we are told that we
already have our first result
of this
round of blitz round one of blitz and he
likes your idea mirov uh wesley so has
defeated shakriar mamindarov
and
wesley uh entered this round one point
out of first place
so he's uh
he's doing his uh job
and this was what you had in mind right
mira was just some kind of a positional
compensation for the pawn
open up the light squares maybe
i'm not sure if it's enough from prior
from you know like objectively but from
practical standpoint you change the
character of the game and this is very
important in blitz i believe and not
only that uh especially against the
world champion
the initiative yeah the initiative the
fact that now white has to watch out as
well for some tricks potentially g3 g2
on tap yeah so there is a check
bishop to c3 knight to f3 on the board
and now knight to d7
97 yes
it's all about exchanging pieces for
magnus right now yeah he swaps the rooks
that he sees he's got a past h pawn
right yeah and that was the bishop
wait a minute are you just completely
lost right now it might be it might just
be that h6 oh wait you have to do
something with this
[Music]
h6 rook f7 for now i mean what can i do
he's done ah he has connected bishop did
play
bishop
check let's not g79 yeah yeah yeah like
has some threats right queen e2 after
rook f7
ah so the queen's the queen is about to
invade unless
our bishop d5 is
bishop d5 is not it doesn't feel like a
bishop g7 now h7 is coming
and that's it and i don't think you can
stop it in fact king b7 okay so
you're trying to promote the queen rook
g7 another queen and then where the
rook's going
it doesn't matter i don't know that's a
lot of wait a second rook g8 and then g3
no i do not agree with you guys i mean
it's blitz after the road what about so
queen to h1 is met by knight to d2
that's a problem yeah rook h7 but g3 i
take on g8 so c7 is a week now this game
all right uh queen takes g8 queen takes
g8 okay very nice uh we've got three
decisive games one game remaining we're
going to jump to it ali raza farouja
versus vessel and topolov
well materially speaking
we're absolutely even but what is the
times we have
we're just getting caught up with the
players
i want seconds literally seconds three
seconds for ali reza in 20 seconds for
vaseline
wow and we just saw a big trade but
knight takes h6 check on tap at least a
whoa
what a move by vessel and rook takes h4
but wait a second what's the clock times
uh seconds for yeah just seconds
well whoa
so he actually controls everything
amazing
great playback
vaseline right now has a good chance no
wait what happened what happened was
that a draw proposition or somebody yeah
was it yeah the question is if if
there's a flag now that was it was it
was a draw okay okay that was how do you
how do you agree with raw they were they
screamed queen e6 check
maybe that was the issue well i think
queen g5 and king to h3 was perhaps the
last move no wait no it was king h3
queen g5 yes so it was white to play so
yes uh we've read the format it said no
draw offers there was no three-fold
repetition by the way as far as i can
see scoreboard says the ball of
one half might have flagged yeah
lost on time that that's what i was
talking about okay five decisive results
for blitz
around number one
that sure shook up the leaderboards
because again
our
leader for uh pardon me jordan coming in
loses to magnus so magnus niall is tied
for ruja loses but wesley wins wesley
wins so it's a three-way tie as far as i
can tell what happened
and
speaking of wesley guys yeah let's see
what happened in uh his game with
mamadiarov with the black pieces he was
actually under a very early attack let's
take a look at what happened we got to
this position of the queen's gambit
declined bishop to b7 queen to e to
knight to d7 and e4 i'm idea of showing
his stuff in this position he wants to
go d5 open up the center as fast as
possible take on d4 take on d4 bishop to
c5 and boom bishop takes e6 mamedyarov
was not shying away from any sort of
complications in this one unfortunately
for him he was also playing wesley saw
who we know that he is cool calm and
collected whenever he's under attack
knight to h5 rook to d8 and the knight
is already being peppered by attacks on
this side h4 losing a lot of temp is
also losing the pawn on e4 and
unfortunately for white they don't have
any initiative on this side anymore the
king is in fact very safe on f7 the
knight on f6 is protecting everything
and the bishop on b7 is such a powerful
piece on the long diagonal and this is
how the game ended knight to d6 knight
takes d6 queen to b3 queen to d5
everything is protected black simply is
up two pieces and mamadirov said okay i
had enough now let's take a look at what
happened in the nepo versus dominguez
game because this one was a very topsy
turvy but take a look at what nepal
brought to the table f4 the king's
gambit incredible d5 take take bishop to
b5 c6 a counter gambit take on c6 knight
take c6 knight to c3 bishop to d6 and
actually it was black who felt like had
the better position out of the opening
but unfortunately for dominguez he was
unable to tame the beast in the end game
which is quite surprising king to a b1
take on e4 f3 d5 bishop to c5 rook to f1
rook to d8 at this point after rook two
e5 f2 was a very powerful move just set
up this pawn on f2 ready for promotion
defended by the bishop on c5 and in fact
it is black who has the better side of
this end game he did not play this move
he played bishop to d4 rook to g5 h6 and
still it was black but after bishop
takes h6 it feels like white is getting
slowly and slowly back into the game you
can withdraw with this bishop on
f4 cut the action of the rook also rook
to g6 and king to h7 was a big mistake
and after king to c2 it feels like the
position still goes on nevertheless i do
believe that dominguez also flagged at
this point because the game just ended
after rook to e5 quite an interesting uh
setup in this round and uh guys in
croatia what do you have what games did
you look at
guys we're looking at that game between
the vessels
and all the rest of you
had a chance to catch up with the
players as wrestling
what happened anastasia tell us what
happened in that game yeah i mean it was
a really crazy game but we just had they
were chatting everybody was laughing
because sex
draw to early respirator and he accepted
but according to the rules you cannot
offer a draw well
i think the results will stand because
they didn't say anything to the players
while they just finished so draw between
alerts of uruguay and wrestling topolof
take us through what happened in that
game yeah it was a long theoretical line
and actually
played this line all the way until movie
three against the tapalla the powerblade
against
back in 2009 and then okay the game
continued and then i think alireza
played very well he didn't get any
troubles i managed to equalize the war i
think at a certain point his position
looked
really good and after all these
exchanges on the queen side you can see
that his pieces are more active and
after
a few more exchanges followed you can
see that white ended up with this d3
pawn right and
i mean i think black is doing really
well yeah but later on
vaseline actually played really bravely
he tried to put his pieces on the king's
side
using the fact that the
white squares not so a little bit weak
right so he tried to play on the king
side until it was it paid him off i mean
at the end of the day you saw what
happened i mean this some after some
mess and d4 uh white managed to find
these all these streaks and king went
all the way to h4 yes somewhere here and
at the end of the day it was a draw yeah
yeah complicated draw especially
considering that it's against the rules
but
i think we're gonna let it slip this
time i had my eyes on the game between
mbl and eva shardic and this was an
incredible game it was a bangkok-style
structure i'm going to skip ahead from
the opening and take you to the good
stuff after rook a3 yvonne went in with
this queen and we got this crazy where
yvonne sirich recovered his pawn here
with the move queen takes a3 and it
looks like black is doing great you got
a nice banquet structure yes the spawn
on b5 looks like it's strong but
actually it's very difficult to make
progress with it because the bishop is
going to block in front of it on b7 and
that means that the knights on e5 the
knight and f6 have excellent positions
to attack white's position how let me
show you
castles bishop b7 ruby one we eventually
got position and maxim missed an
absolute brilliancy knight ft7 here and
let's go to this position maxine plays
the move f4 kicking out this knight on
e5 very powerful knight you want to get
rid of it you might he might have
expected the move knight ed will be a
very natural move but after bishop to
xg7 king takes g7 queen d2 we've talked
before about the superfluous knights
they go on the same square you don't
really want to have this connection
between the knights so it's a nice
knight on d3 but it's a bit unstable and
instead
ivan uncorked this super sexy move
knight b3 it's just an awesome move even
in a classical game look at the tactical
point f takes e5 knight takes d4 queen
takes e4 bishop takes e5 this hits a lot
of pieces the queen on d4 the knight on
c3 and the knight on g3 it looks like
white can defend everything with the
move queen e3
and still
queen c5 forces the trait of queens and
the knights cannot defend each other
because the opponent e4 is on the way
the bishop on e2 is on the way so you
actually get your piece back with an
advantage it was looking brilliant for
the croatian player but unfortunately
for him he just lost the threat on a
total bluff after rook a3 maxime saw his
position was collapsing he's having
trouble on the third rank the bishops
are powerful and he uncorks this
sacrifice bishop takes h5 as you can see
lee chess hates it
but ivan he believed his opponent and
that's the problem with a minute left he
decided not to take the bishop it looked
dangerous to him because of knight takes
h5 the queen coming to cheers dangerous
it does look dangerous unfortunately the
other
way he played was even more dangerous
for him because after queen e3 look at
maxine he just collected the king's side
f takes g6 was played queen takes c3 and
unfortunately for yvonne i think he must
have underestimated the
queen g4
beautiful pieces on the queen side okay
that's nice but you're king it's on the
other side of the board you have to
bring it back nia 5 coming there's
nothing you can do about it and after a
couple of spy checks knight of three
check maxine this set no i'm not even
going to take that knight king h1
instead nothing to be done about the
checkmate threats on the king's side
very calm move very collected and the
players they're having a laugh over
there they were having fun with the
games they're analyzing outside of our
studio during rounds with the remaining
games it's a great spectacle over here
in zagreb and we're just a few minutes
away from starting round number two
what a what a great way to start
thank you honestly
alejandro you guys sure having a lot of
fun uh brilliant explanation there the
game this is the very end
of the topologia
we have a rule no draw offers the
players temporarily forgot
their you in blitz everything happened
so quickly mero they just don't have any
any any uh
and is it that according to the rules if
they did agree to a draw both of them
get zero points is that how it works no
i don't think so i think they're just
going to allow the draw to stand because
they just
both players seem to have accepted the
draw so but they may get awarded at this
point if we can
not cover the clock with his hand maybe
he has still seven seconds so he
definitely didn't flag he definitely did
not he didn't flag no and that's why
instead of five decisive games uh we
have four decisive games one draw again
draw offers not allowed as we said and
it's just like one of those temporary
things that you forget and here's our
standings
round one and the three people have
tightened up yeah the three are in the
lead right so one for rest loses and
he's getting caught up by magnus carlsen
and wesley saw ali
half a point behind only 11 for mbl and
ten for jan nippon good job nepal
exactly as we see these uh
uh blitz uh specialist nepo and mbl but
for magnus is this third
win in a row if we go back to the rapid
so he's definitely getting his mojo
working vessel and topple off still
struggling
and for round two's pairings bureau yeah
the ivan suarez will be facing one
forest
love against carlson right might still
remember playing carson when he was a
little boy
right so wesley saw against ali reza
ferrun that will be our marquee matchup
by the way we'll keep our eye on that as
the start but please continue absolutely
dominguez against mohammed yarov and and
we yell against nippon
quite an interesting match absolutely
that will be our backup but wesley so
again we've spoken about wesley as just
doing his thing which is not losing and
he just scores and he picks up a point
here he picks up a point there very
impressive his consistency christian
absolutely and he's shown that in the
grand chess tour year after year i can
only remember last year's paris event
where he uh just blasted through uh the
competition just incredible player
incredible consistency and whenever
especially in rapid and blitz i have to
say he doesn't lose much we know that he
doesn't lose in classical and he hates
losing but also he doesn't lose very
often in rapid and blitz sometimes he is
taken out of the event by making too
many draws in fact this is not the case
in this one he's winning games he's
allowing his opponents to as he did in
the last one sacrifice on e6 you take
the chances and i will defend and this
is exactly what he's doing right now
he's very precise absolutely and i just
wanted to say for alejandro and
anastasia the game they highlighted
there ivan saric versus nbo that is like
it it it showcases blitz and all of its
spills and thrills uh kind of the
sacrifices you bluff your opponent yeah
absolutely yeah i mean you wish that the
games would be as logical as rapid on
classical but yeah they're not and
that's part of an excitement exactly
exactly it's uh what makes
everybody who played uh
uh
so much fun and i recall that going back
to bobby fischer
he really liked blitz and kasparov and
karpov love to play blitz and you gotta
learn to roll with
the punches there and again this is
going to be our marquee matchup
alireza is a an nba fan guys i mean i
was about to call that he's sporting the
chicago bulls fan maybe yeah the [ __ ]
the swag absolutely remind me what
happened in the rapid game
um
well wesley has wesley did you lose so
far
fair enough i will say it was a draw
but i'm not guaranteeing that
but
only lost one game
and i think it was in the last um
last round against jordan i don't think
he has lost the scene that's right that
that's so a draw
so
elimination by deductive
deductive reasoning absolutely
um
and nepo you know i don't know but the
first day or two of rapid
he wasn't feeling it i mean he just
wants to keep it he might as well be
happy yeah
i i i'm sure everybody was put off by
the whole magnus carlos announcement you
know that and uh
reflecting on ian as well
uh ian in the interview about uh
magnus said he's disappointed
and he
you have to be right
you want to play uh
the best
right absolutely so magnus was
disappointed himself by his announcement
yes yeah and was disappointed with
magnus's announcement but now you've
mentioned magnus caught three out of
three yeah the last three games but the
end that did the same right
and uh the young guns the evan sarich
the local hero on the left jordan then
forrest what will he bring
by the way
magnus said jordan you may be beating
everybody else but he won the rapid that
was two points for magnus he knows him
so well that's three he knows him so
well
it just goes to show through the opening
choice as well uh jordan is not getting
a lot of chances in their encounters
well after this point he also played
black both games
good point so he was back but i was also
very disappointed with jordan he came
out of that opening that blitz just
perfect shape then he played knight a4
what the heck was knight a4 he misplaced
his knight he could have played 96
when mira we were kind of getting
ourselves
warmed to the task we thought that he
might have had an advantage against the
world champion with black but knight a4
stepped in the wrong direction and
um
f2 f4 came but just giving up the queen
was not the right solution at that point
okay i'll tell that to miro he shouldn't
have listened to me
i'm a commentator not a player exactly
here we go
berlin
and rookie one once again uh-oh
are we going to see something very very
tepid if so well this is the opening in
win ali rezal lost his only a game in
this game exactly
but this was not the
yeah that's the line rookie 1 rookie
okay rookie one queen e1 bishop d4 was
what
um
was played that uh no more taking the
pawn but no more
90 yeah okay this is tools
sorry uh this feels a little toothless
to us we're going to make a should we go
to magnus yes
an executive decision let's see former
world champion
veselyn toppa tupalov
playing against soon-to-be
former world champ
uh magnus carlson
bishop yeah but this is with bishop e7
now this one i actually always knew as
the hungarian defense um of the joke of
of the two knights not really no that's
what we called it i don't know what it
is
that one would be just two knights
defense with d3 and then it's not a lot
you can do you can transpose the joker
piano or you can play your bishop e7
what strikes me as an odd those are
technicalities the position you are
getting is pretty much the same yeah
with the bishop on e7 yeah rook e8
magnus is spending a lot of time up to
this point four minutes and 30 seconds
and only four minutes for magnus
surprising because
you would expect magnus would be let's
say better prepared
than topalov
well with this bishop on f8 magnus is
showing
some preparation from dubai he put his
bishop on f8 in his world championship
match
against nepo and nepo
never dented
him as white it's time for d4 yeah
you got to get in that break yeah i'm
i'm guessing what made magnus think
well for more than a minute is the fact
that the knights on c3 right because
yeah it's not very useful for this
setups exactly the knight you play the
joke of piano yeah you go c3 and then
the knight goes the you know the real
opposite way the spanish way d2 f1 and
then g3 or e3 can oh uh i was about to
say d4
if knight g6 there was a very
interesting
pawn hunting exercise taking on a5
trading queens and knight b5 perhaps
fearing that that would work
magnus made a decision that
well he gave up the centers but then he
had 98 at the end right yeah yes
and i was going pawn hunting with knight
a7 but uh that's a completely
nice you're right you're a bracelet i
like to see six yeah no it's their
pieces i'm sacrificing uh
christian knight back to c6 okay
uh bishop e3 if you take twice there is
a bishop
well bishop f7 no
no not really no no queen d5 there is
rook e6
sorry but it feels like capturing only
four is extremely dangerous e55
taking the bull by the horns putting a
lot of pressure on f7 for example if you
take on d4 i'm going to capture back
with the queen and if you do take on e5
we're going to exchange the queens take
on e5 with the knight and then put a lot
of pressure on f7 which will give white
a better end game with the knight on e5
and the bishop on c4 pressing f7 you
like white's initiative e5 was
how do you think kind of camouflaged
it wasn't an obvious move but i think
with your
better development as white yeah that's
one of the ways right to capitalize on
your own development yeah yeah
breakthrough open the position because
maybe if you start to be too mindful
like okay i will not give you a chance
to exchange my bishop and so black will
solidify and be okay yeah catch up so
you have a lead and then yeah try to
break through yeah bishop e6 would if
black had the opportunity to play bishop
e6 he would simply trade off the act of
bishop so good move by uh vessel and
gets
gets the stamp of approval from
ourselves
and magnus is down to almost two minutes
almost two minutes behind his opponent
wow wrestling with three minutes and 45
seconds magnus with only two minutes
right now
and then i take these perhaps we're
going straight into that and it takes d4
what you've recommended
yeah and it does seem to be it does seem
to be better for white yeah okay so now
we trade on d8 it's not much black can
do but
recapture the queen 95 bishop e6 that's
that's much better the thing about
accepting this endgame is that you know
you're most likely not going to win this
one no um in any scenario unless
vaseline makes a big mistake along the
way he's not going to lose this one but
knight d3 right here right now
and i love white's position the knight
on d3 blocks the d file knight d3 king
f7 yeah and then you just double up but
the the rooks maybe something like
rookie three
or yeah sometimes the rook may go to f3
so knight d3 double up the rooks and
it's play on one goal
the e6 pawn
is tender
yeah
okay toppolov is
considering perhaps some and just to
give you an update on the other marquee
a match-up of the round wesley saw in
fiorusia nothing has happened in that
one
so i think the executive decision was a
good one
we we call them the way we see um
what's your take on this position white
for choice but uh if you were to give it
a numerical
um
um i would say one one pawn one point
plus one plus one plus one really yeah i
think it's that good also by the way
you are right plus 1.2
but it's a plus that you can play very
quickly like for
on your when you're on the white side
you can see your next four or five moves
almost like telegraphed ooh
knight c4 protects d2
but the problem is doesn't that invite
rook d4
knight d3 sure it does
knight c4
so that at least protects the d2 and
three now rook to d4 a very aggressive
approach night weight five five ninety
five's bit surprising this allows rook
to d2 in a lot of scenarios
maybe how about now how about right now
i'm not sh well then
the knight was sent on a mission
rook to e2 i think you have to because
rook to c1 is going to be met by bishop
to c5 i don't like that one and we're
seeing a little head shaking going on he
does not like the situation right now
[Music]
and by the way
topalov caught up with magnus on the
clock because he took a 45 second thing
in a blitz game for that move knight to
c4 move i didn't like it and what rook
d8 would be perhaps the most unpleasant
for topology no question he goes for it
no question about it
seeing you with your initiative can you
have won those and now
rook d2 rooks
he won and then kicked the rook off this
night i'm covering i'm covering all of
the
weak squares
if thessalon can get in the move king e1
he might yet
gain some advantage he has
still after all the better structure
that we thought he had the better
structure and the more active pieces a
moment ago rook to d5 okay can we
actually snap one piece
yeah that's what i was thinking
to get rid of that weak weak pawns yeah
knight to knight b3 i think it's time
for vaseline to pull the brakes
so now it gives black some kind of
breathing room right right so go knight
c3 go rook to d1 exchange the rooks and
make a draw right it's time
if magnus allows it 94
94 stars no knight c3 wait a second
knight f4
you know vessel sometimes suffers from
too great an activity like sometimes
he should be just knight to d3 you know
playing solid moves but what about an
idea of c5 c4 right now
c are you going to meet c5 with c4
yourself f4 and then you have b5 wow
exactly well
crazy you know crazy complicated but b5
is c1
b5 rook c1 i have to play rookie one
perhaps to kick back the knight that
knight e4
is too strong it's just too strong yeah
well actually after magnus is c5 i have
to say that
you know it might
once again come white's way
the pendulum is definitely swinging i i
really like this move rook to e1 by the
way well i mean the rook hasn't moved
since the beginning of the game c4 is
his decision
and by the way van forrest is uh
storming the lead right now he won his
game so he won his game against sarge he
only has one problem in this tournament
and magnus carlsen he's magnus carlson
yeah
wesley
yeah
beats him
how about that well yeah he's coming
back slowly but surely
he has an idea about how to play blitz
games okay he know b5 by the way maybe
b5 next c4 knight d6 so he attacks c4
with that we defend with rook c1 and
then b5
no then i get to play
knight a5 or knight d2
b6 was solid solid choice i don't like
this move c4 by vaseline rook to e1 was
a much
better move i have a feeling i do too i
do too because now the bishop has a
square on d4 with the pawn on c2 right
or the knight potential you move
yeah
and i'm guessing our knight on b3 our
knight if
we were to play white yeah our knight on
b3 is not doing you know no we i i
really want to bring it to
d2 and if possible e4 but
the knight on b3 i agree with your whole
heart the five mirror is just not good
that's four four wait a sec does g4 pick
up this pawn whereabouts and that's that
that's what toppolov is asking as well
did you plunder pawn mr carson not
really rook f6 he's going to take play
rookie six yeah well you've kind of
committed once you've played the e6 do
we go g5 or bishop f6
bishop f6 even if you take on e5 i'll
make a draw knight d2 but g5 is the
worst g fine
it's always very serious right you
cannot
wow completely unawares of the clock he
just lost contact with the position uh
let's switch where are we going wesley
so
much left yes it's
wesley so for ruja not much left we're
expecting a draw we're going to see a
repetition
the bishop is anchored
but there's a weakness of uh the f7 pawn
the ships have opposite color
cam linear
oh i'm having a transmission relay i see
they're making a lot of moves but yeah
think it's very very common
well unfortunately my board isn't being
updated we're just gonna have to stay
with the bird's eye view as best we can
there we go okay how do we feel about
this position i want to say sure defense
winning but drop
things before did he count them
precisely well
we'll see we'll see
he did count it precisely because it's
just great jokes by the way king rook f5
rook five is beautiful rook f5 is
beautiful
why don't you get to e6 man king d5 king
e6 and take on f6 yeah that's the way
well he didn't spoil anything because
yeah that's why he has an instrument
there
he's going right to king and by the way
a very very nice
play there by lanier at the very end i
didn't think that that was
winning at least when we got into it but
at the end
uh he took
and once again this is vessel and
toppola flagging from
he's completely never looks at the clock
he's completely unaware
[Laughter]
the flag fell
and uh christian uh what caught your eye
well let's take a look at what happened
in that uh wesley versus furuja game not
a lot has happened and let's take a look
i think we left it somewhere around here
we said that we're moving on from this
game because it's just simply too
symmetrical and unless one of the
players makes a big mistake then nothing
is going to change and nothing did
change in the position queen to g3
bishop to h4 another piece was traded
another piece was traded and now all
black has to do is put the record on e8
exchange uh some major pieces go into
the bishop end game and just simply make
a draw and this is exactly what happened
and uh yeah uh an end game without much
history but let's take a look at the
game between dominguez and mamedyarov
they started off with the rui lopez
knight to d5 a very intriguing option by
white castle c3 preparing the break in
the center with d4 as well as uh
attacking the hook on b5 with the move
a4 and putting a lot of pressure on the
queen side d4 followed by h3 bishop to
e3 take on d5 this was the moment right
now after bishop to b6 rook to c1 queen
to f6 e5 came on the board this was a
very important break just open up the
position open up the center uh propose
some exchanges as well as take advantage
of the weaknesses specifically the
weakness on c7 the pawn on c7 once we
exchange the dark square bishops this
pawn on c7 is going to be in trouble and
queen to f5 was played but unfortunately
this end game is just really bad for
black after bishop to c6 rook takes d6
bishop to e8 white uh got the exchange
and went on to convert smoothly in that
end game that we caught the end of and
let's take a look at what happened in
zagreb guys
why do you
it what do you guys have for us in
zagreb
thank you christian we have some great
games but
you had your eyes on one of the leaders
of the tournament and he keeps on
winning as soon as he loses to magnus
unbelievable yeah maybe he gets you know
so excited to play against him and he i
mean he's so strong magnus that all the
others maybe for him phil will not
know what's going on but he all the time
he wins after that games right and also
it was very interesting to see to the
nepal against them well before the game
i don't saw it on the video but they
were chatting together they were
laughing checking some variations from
the previous round it's nice to see them
you know in this kind of atmosphere you
can always find all those short videos
in instagram and now in our social media
follow us and you will see more
information camaraderie here is amazing
take us over this game event sideways
with white pieces against morden von
forest didn't go well for the korean
again yes i don't know i mean it was
just some kind of
anti-lean and it was some struggle in
the open and it seems like um
didn't mind that his opponent and the
white is trying not to get rid of the
phone and distribute this
phone but you see what happened after
black had everything under control and
after a few exchanges 96 um
again 96 i mean exchanging the queens
moving to the ending and look what
happened at the very end black got
really great position he controls d file
um pawns a4 before our week and even
though the material is still equal i
mean it's not easy to play for white
despite the fact that we have opposite
color bishop's position was really
unpleasant and that's what happened
actually while collapsed in a couple of
moves rook b3 it seems like more or less
rook d1 is seems bad move but even after
bishop c3 protecting the opponent before
rook d3 you can see even without
calculating that uh black pieces are
active and why it has to struggle here
so in the game it was pretty easy for a
dutch player i mean after rook d1 and
bishop b6
yeah it was a small trick yes if rook b2
there was this small check yes it was a
small trick so he just defended against
this one and after that the position of
black is really really great so it took
him not so much time to convert it uh so
what do you have alejandro
that's a great way for jordan and of
course that puts him in first place with
and they were being so
friendly
yes before the game they were just
chatting they were joking
and a
friendly game they got this patch of
symmetrical petrov queen e7 ability all
right
straight the queens no
maxine
you know what let's change up a little
bit blaze move c4 and the strategically
risky decision in this case to give
yourself an isolated pawn when the
queens are not on specifically this pawn
on d4 will become very weak as we'll see
it cannot be defended by any piece sorry
any pawn adjacent to it that's why we
call it an isolated pawn and even though
this king on f8 it's a little off place
it didn't compensate for the long-term
weakness of the pawn on d4 and that's
what happened in the game maxim actually
also collapsed pretty quickly in this
position after knight ft5 rook ac one
his position has sort of become a bit
unpleasant yes he has activity yes his
roof turned open files but long term he
doesn't have great prospects yes you're
lost
about this there's no point of attack
there's no point to pressure black's
position spawn on c7 you see this rook
has pressure on this guy max and nepo
says f6 and c6 now you can't enter the
knight doesn't have e5 the pawn on c6 is
solidly defended no problems for black
and without a plan playing blitz is
really hard and at this point
it's already obvious that black has
consolidated brought their rook from h8
to d8 is ready to start pressuring this
weakness on d4 and just no real plan for
white still
networked up picking up this pawn on d5
and the rest was pretty easy for the
challenger because let's be honest
that's a lot in this case it's also hard
to play this position uh maxime traded
off into that but it's unfortunately for
him completely lost and nepo simply
brought up his king all the way to c5
the last move is illegal and with b5 and
a5 coming
followed by b4 it's just completely
just a huge amount i can say first of
all that it was a great example for
everybody who can understand how to play
against isolated pawn this game was
really perfect i think from the point of
view it was perfect even though it was a
blitz game yeah it's like perfect
and the second and also this one the
position i don't know why he gave up so
easily so quickly but it's lost yet oh
it's completely lost well that means
that nepo is slightly surging but we
have two leaders here in zagreb magnus
carlsen and jordan van fors we're gonna
take a short commercial break and we'll
be back with round three of the blitz
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of zagreb here are our
standings miro after two rounds of blitz
uh yeah and you guys might be surprised
but you see familiar name in the first
position in the standings it's magnus
carlsen
so who's leading the tournament along
with euron jordan one forest
uh half a point behind is the wesley saw
slow and steady right maybe not that
flashy performance but he wins a lot and
he never lost a single game yet right
ali reza is on 12 and two guys on eleven
yandy from michigan maximus yellow graph
nebo is coming back guys yeah well you
can see the two zero scores for magnus
and nepo as you're absolutely right i
think that's six points in a row because
he did win his last two rapid games
isn't he
i believe you're right that that might
be six points in a row for jan
i think that would explain his very good
mood and let's take a look at the
pairings for round three miro do the
honors please yes and nepo will face
ivan sarich might as well continue his
you know his trick mommy jaroff against
mvl ferruccia dominguez is one of the
interesting games one for rest with
white against the polyp can he do it
again he crushed the follow with white
right and the game will be concentrating
the most is of course magnus carlsen
against wesley saw a nice marquee
matchup to be sure but uh jordan van
forest still up there at the very very
top remarkable uh surreal he said we
must be staying with magnus versus
wesley yeah exactly now wesley was very
very fortunate to draw with white in the
rapid
um somehow wesley
hates
he's a little bit i want to say magnus
bullies him
can i put it like that yeah
is that unfair no that that'd be
absolutely fair because remember not
only wesley barely escape was white but
this scenario there was magnus played
this love wesley went for an exchange
staff
was officer ford refused to get yeah
remember he offered the repetition and
wesley kind of took it and magnus said
no i want to play with black from
arguably slightly worse position because
i'm stronger than you exactly so that's
that's the bullying part the factor that
i'm talking about and it's the joko
piano
uh with d3
d7 d6 none of this h6 a5s none of these
strange moves and magnus
early knight d2 that that is that is an
interesting one quickly came a5
yeah again neither light f1 yeah so
that's what they are trying to do with
this early 92 thing yes so he wants to
go knight f1 knight g3 presumably then
castle and spare tempo and rook f
one to e1
right because usually you castle earlier
and then to
find the route for this knight you have
to move the rook as well right exactly
so now he does it with the saving of a
tempo so to speak yeah at the same time
there's so many routes for this knight
right you can go knight a3 knight c2
knight e3 and then knight to f5 or
wherever you want to put it if you do
want to put on a put it on g3 you do
have to pass through f1 though exactly
bishop e6 inviting a trade no says
magnus bishop b5 sometimes we see queen
to b8 in this positions right yes he
went knight e7 queen b8 queen a7 knight
e7 knight g6 but keep in mind white is
the one who is ready to play
d3 d4
with
a break in the center um
like g6 let's play so default on the
board
and
gosh i'm always trying to weigh and
compare
between a rui lopez uh kind of position
in the current setup
and uh
in this moment i i'm not sure that it
makes such a big difference but after
h7h6 no
e5 takes d4 and knight takes
yeah that amazes me how often it happens
so that they play c3d4 implying that i
want to build the strong center and they
end up
capturing with the piece with the piece
and not the pawn i'm sure had he
captured with the c pawn
e
uh pardon me uh
d5 would have been
wesley's answer as well okay two bishops
but this bishop
has this very very very powerful
diagonal i wanted to say white has the
two bishops
but it's black who's looking at this f2
pawn
knight takes e4 is that ridiculous ideas
of queen h4 he went queen c7 also ideas
secretly hoping yeah
secretly hoping
uh by the way that's an awkward move
yeah that's me interesting the threat is
so obvious yeah if tupon is pinned so
i'll i'm threatening to capture on g3
but how do you but if you sidestep
avoided
it's hard to say if you can avoid it
comfortably yeah the the problem is if
we sidestep with king h1 to get off of
the pin
and to avoid queen takes g3 then bishop
takes f2
is going to kick the legs out from
underneath the knight
knight moves knight takes e4 you know
what i think magnus might be in a bit of
a trouble absolutely no question about
it
and the world champion there
looks a little annoyed with himself as
he's realizing
the same thing actually
this is
i mean i don't like to play move like
knight h5 not the least of which is
knight takes e4 and how do i win my pawn
back
knight h5 knight takes e4 we trade in
queen g4
forgive me that i to my audience that i
don't move the pieces but for the moment
we want to make sure
that we have both the bird's eye view as
well as the live position
so but knight h5 knight e4 so that's a
stop yeah knight h5 was well he might
exchange one h5 queen g3 on its own
magnus is already down a minute on the
clock yeah that's a lot against wesley
it's a lot
because
it's such an awkward move to play and
wow
very
quickly not bishop takes f2
but pawn takes e4
in this line he could not play the
bishop
f2 because the knights guarded right so
we're discussing
h1 yes
yes but now he's put himself in it yeah
he captures the pawn the knight on g3 is
pin but also i can start thinking about
ideas of playing h5h4 absolutely
with the king on h2 now i understand you
probably want to actually coax me into
doing that and when you play h5 go king
to h1 say that i weaken my position like
that
but this is it's an initiative that
needs to be
self-positioned by the looks of it such
an unpleasant position would you guys
would have been tempted to play knight
takes e4 as opposed to
d takes e4 because knight takes e4 would
have
forced bishop takes e4 and then the rook
would have already been on the f file
yeah yeah i like this move queen to e2
uh setting up not only bishop take c4
but also bishop to e3 i think that's
much more important the spawn on e4 is
likely to fall but that move bishop e3
okay knight f4 right is it time for
knight f4 i think so
but then he can capture and still take
on e4 right even though the knight spin
yes
again white is the one trying to
equalize absolutely uh at this moment
perhaps queen to c4 is an option
all right
it might be but but it feels wrong i
mean moving the queen away everything
feels wrong right now yeah
there's a lot of problems in the
position for why not a question position
yeah no question about it and i'm
beginning to warm up to h5 as well
that uh
if i could get
my
how do we pull the brakes for a magnus
exactly
is it time to take on f4 and go rook to
e1 i think so
and really focus on that e4 pawn at the
same time not only that you recapture
your last pawn but also uh force or
intimate that you want to exchange more
pieces in the position
absolutely well again when you're
looking for a bailout resource
usually it begins with
trades
bishop f4 we suspect
uh queen c4 uh by the way magnus down to
his last minute 50 seconds against three
minutes
he's not happy
and this is what i was saying h5 i'm
warming up to h5 something to be said
for 93 93 93 i take and take only six
true but you're not
you still have to equalize that position
there's a pawn on d3 and rook comes rook
two a to e2
uh but that's one another move if you
want to just play simple chess
d8 rook d8
uh
and finally your move h5 he played rook
d8 i like that move i do too bishop e3
what else you've uh bishop e4 is an
alternative the thing about bishop to e3
you can't even
go bishop to b8
he comes back c4 is on the board he
captures so what does black do now
so do you sacrifice the pawn take on e4
and oh h5 wow
let's go
why didn't he start with h5 right yeah
well because after king h1 i have h4 and
the bishop e4 is hanging correct
so
the timing is such that no king h1 oh
this is this is a great move
and bishop e3 and magnus is beginning to
feel the ticking clock
and nepal by the way did win his
closing the gap to only one point five
in a row in a row
10 seconds for magnus bishop b8 with the
threat of h4 that looks like five
seconds for magnus killer blow you can't
really find
okay but now rook takes f2 i think it's
over true rook f2 queen e4 i suspect
rook f5 is easiest
and by the way another big result
did bid van forest oh
cinderella's shoe slip a little and look
at magnus he realizes
uh rook h4 rook f5 threat the problem is
you know you're completely lost and your
opponent still has two minutes on the
clock right
real quick
five f4 okay
piece down magnus that's going to be a
piece down
i i don't see wesley messing this one up
there's a bishop check there's a queen
check
somehow you you you have the feeling
that you ought to be able to exploit uh
well knight d2 is an option knight d2 is
and then well the the idea is that the
knight is hanging the rook is he goes
for it yeah queen takes f7 queen f
queen e6 who seconds for magnus by the
way king takes knight g3
king takes knight g3 rook takes f4
correct
and that's simple
that's a p shop
that's the easy one
uh knight takes f1 knight takes
f5 might be a little tricky
oh that's nasty is the rook
can slide in on b2 now yeah okay magnus
tries to you know to imitate some sort
of an attack with right left right a
guerrilla attack with a knight in a rook
but now i can just go rook to d7 correct
bishop f4 is also very attractive just
thank you i don't think you can defend
that pawn
g3 i have knight f3 all the time yes
always knight f3
you're true the pawn on f4 is not
running so actually after rook two d7
almost every single square on the e file
is controlled right you can go to e3 but
then i just go you should pixel d7
and how much time does four seconds for
magnus he needs to make a move rook to
d1 came a little
the bishop f4 like you said that pawn
wasn't running anywhere
bishop f4 yeah
a2 is hanging well not anymore but
magnus was aware that a2 was hanging
now
rook to d5
knight to d4
you almost feel like
black is not winning enough yeah yeah i
mean that that he missed some the g5
bigger opportunity knight f3 if you
should finish the game knight f3 was
just like
it wasn't
was yeah it was knight of three pawn
takes then take it to take the other one
but it's g2 doesn't it doesn't matter
yes g2 is hanging now this is winning
enough now yeah this is overkill in fact
g3 rupee seven okay one check in the row
as they used to say
and the other oh
finally by the way uh
that was a dominating performance i mean
uh welcome by what do we have let's jump
to farouzia versus lanier dominguez
as farouza may have an opportunity to
get a tie for first uh
no no no from the way it looks
yeah even if he wins this one he's not
tied for first oh he's not tight first
he would not win with the winners
he's definitely losing whoa nightway
five
hold on king wait a minute that's a rook
but that's a knight c3 that's okay uh
that's going to be a piece up for
dominguez
king to b3 but knight way five what's
that is a real one i mean he's
i apologize you're absolutely right is
clock
factors linears
does linear you have any time five
seconds uh for a linear and only before
the length is known for this like you
watch the guy and you do not suspect
he's the wealth blitz champion yeah he
makes sometimes his moves with last
second on the clock but never flags
never like that so always close but
never a flag right no resignation for
from fearuja yeah unexpected
well i remember uh from here that was
enough
uh
from his book bullet chess uh nakamura's
advice in bullet chess never ever ever
resign
get mated that you you could flag your
opponent big victory there big
and finally yes finally we have it four
uh sorry for not four but we had four
five decisive games five no jokes
no draw offers no no no
uh no quarter being offered uh christian
what caught your eye let's take a look
at what happened in the other games and
nepo once again won quite a smooth and
easy game and uh he started off not with
the kings gambit in this one but with
knight to f3 the king's indian attack c4
queen to a4 queen takes c4 and now this
uh transposes into almost an english
type position we've seen a nepo win a
lot of games in this type of structures
he understands the nuances and this is
exactly what he's showcasing in this
game and let's take a look knight to c3
knight to b6 controlling the knight with
the move b3 i really like this move d3
bishop to f5 and after bishop to h3 it
already feels like black has lost too
many tempest to exchange the light
square bishops at the same time you have
to tend uh content with the fact that
knight to c5 is coming and you will have
some real time difficulties with the
pawn on b7 a lot of
ideas of knight to c5 even if you defend
that pawn knight takes b7 if i go rook
to c1 and then the knight on c6 is going
to hang so that's a big problem for
black knight to be for trying to
get rid of that problem once you
exchange the dark square bishops h4 h5
is coming and with the king on g2 i have
the idea of rook to h1 you have to stop
me with the move h5 the problem is that
weakens your structure even more and the
king side as well and immediately nepo
takes advantage of that queen to e5
queen to f4 getting the queen to h6
closer to the king knight to d5 and
after queen to h6 it just feels like i
have too many pieces around your king
you have to allocate too many resources
to the defense of the king on g8 which
allows me to take that weakness that i
was talking about five minutes ago the
pawn on b7 and this is the problem and
of course after that nepo went on to win
a very smooth end game very easy win for
nepo now let's take a look at what
happened in van forest versus topalov
this was a shocking turn of events let's
take a look
it started off as this innocuous
sicilian which actually uh transposed
into something that looked more like a
rui lopez with the bishop on g5 take on
f6 and now the knight is transitioning
towards the d5 square knight to d to
knight to c4 knight to f1 knight to e3
and uh aiming that square d5 and this is
exactly what we see b5 nothing actually
happened all the way to this point or at
least not as many imbalances came on the
board this game looked like a game that
was going to end up in a drop but then
this move came rook takes e5 huge
blunder why is it a blunder because of
this beautiful tactic motif queen to a1
check getting the king on h2 and rook to
d6 this is it this is over you take on
d6 i take on e5 the problem is this also
captures your queen the queen on d6 uh
the bishop 25 is defended by the queen
on a1 just a beautiful tactic and to be
honest after rook to d6 this just forces
resignation uh he did play on rook to e4
rook takes d5 but this is just a queen
for a rook and this was all she wrote
guys and dominguez also wins his game
against ferugia quite an exciting round
i have to say but wesley so once again
showing his consistency in this event as
well as his precision what a game by
west wonderful and our standings miro
with three rounds in the history books
uh yeah so we've got a new leader it's
wesley saw after this win magnus carlsen
and jordy van forrest are still tied but
this time for the second right valley
razor losing means that yam
floated up yep so we have another tie
here for the fourth place it's ali reza
and jan
notice that mvl lost a very important
game against shaq riyar if mvl one of
our blitz specialists at one he would be
up there with twelve but wesley slow
clear first
uh
good defense and good offense wins
tournaments not a very good time to be
at
leader in the tournament i'm going to go
look at the game between shaq and mvl
for just a moment came
from a grunfeld
with e3 remember shaq played this
against him in
and they reached this ending
and i just wanted to get your take
because i think for a lot of grunfeld
players they would say that this is an
ending that they like i mean after all
the the the knight is really nicely in
the center these dark squares
h2 is potentially weak but
nvl went down pretty fast yeah that
there were things happening before this
yeah it happened on the board yeah right
but it seemed like and pardon me it
seemed to me that shaq was aiming for
this ending a position
i think likes doing pretty absolutely
and it went very very fast
that suddenly
uh
well i just wanted to say that uh
white was uh two results
but i think black was perfectly fine
still until the moment when mvl
went for the sacrifice
ah this
he apparently thought that somehow those
pawns are promoted right but he did get
actually an equal position even after
that even afternoon
yes
really
because rook ah rook check uh
this was a game that
this was wild guys i mean
lots of uh ups and downs in this one
real well very unexpected was that move
akin to e1
right right here yes that was the big
move king to e1 after king to c3 you
have to give up the bishop
because there is a knight
and a check so then
totally different
with the king
close to this pawn and the knight coming
back white would still be having to draw
this exactly now you can also go king to
f1 and maybe this was what he was afraid
of after king to c3 king to f1 and allow
knight takes c6 yeah
rook takes is the problem there exactly
but i don't see rook two c7 king to b4
uh rook d4 yeah rook d4 that was the
problem of the king c3 i mean once again
i'm not using the engines i might be
wrong so yeah with the tax and bishop b5
and i'm just on time to pick it up and
by the way now that you mentioned i have
the right
bishop looks pretty good uh
wow but once again what a very
topsy-turvy round for the tournament
leaders
as uh
magnus goes down
and
jordan goes down and ali riza uh goes
down wow
uh good stuff and what do we have
coming up for round four do we know our
appearance oh yeah of course we know
yeah yeah just the outcome was a very
very smart observation right after that
i read the pairing so saric against
toppolov so two outsiders right right uh
wesley saw the leader will be facing
forest dominguez got to be a kind of a
marquee game yeah dominguez faces magnus
carlsen and two frenchmen players
together
and we all will have the white pieces
against
nepal surging sergeant nepal will face
mommy giaro cool so wesley so jordan van
poorest our marquee matchup our plan b
has to be linear magnus yeah and the
french derby looking pretty good as well
again sorry for the little disturbances
with zagreb but we will get that fixed
we have something yeah absolutely uh so
look i was um i used to be not that bad
at math i'm just trying to add my two
plus two right uh we said that uh we
have a very high percentage of
decisive games and then paired with the
fact that
wesley
is not losing any games
well it seems to be the recipe for
success right i mean you don't make a
lot of draws because because the high
percentage of decisive games then you
don't list exactly and here you have it
wesley leading the tournament yeah no
and
also
for for me what's very impressive is
like uh not the fact that he's not
losing but the fact that he's saving
these very difficult positions
and he's kind of doing it in an
impressive style christian just jump
right in uh you you're an experienced
blitz player
how is it that wesley manages to
slip
it's a very good question i have to say
he's
impressing me uh quite a lot especially
this last game against magnus we saw him
defending uh worse positions but in this
one he wasn't worse he actually knew the
opening better knew the nuances of the
middle game better and just simply
outplayed the world champion and after
that after he got a winning position he
made the most precise moves that knight
to f4 and then h5 at the precise moment
and by the way we were looking at this
game just to kind of end that parallel
the game between um mamedyarov and mvl
and you guys pointed out this moment at
the end
and it's a very educational one because
it does seem that after king to c3 um
what was the move that we were
mentioning king to f1
take was that it
no bishop takes f3 what was the end game
that oh rook takes d4 yes this was it
but then you can take take on f3 and now
i go b5 yeah
this was the way to make a draw because
you have to take on b5 but then i just
simply catch up this pawn you have to
defend it and then i'm going to move
this pawn you have to
allocate that resource to the defense of
this pawn and then uh that's just going
to allow me to take the pawn on b5 and
make a draw so this was the way to make
a draw of course with a couple of
seconds on the clock calculating all
these ideas and all these variations is
pretty much impossible you have to play
instinctively and this is exactly what
he did i don't blame him i mean king to
e1 it does look like you're getting a
queen very quickly right but bishop to
b5 would have in fact defended against
that because if you go check into g2
knight takes b5 now i can give a check
i'm not going to take on b5 and allow
you to promote i'm going to give a check
and this is just a simple win for white
quite an intriguing end game but with
only a few seconds it was mamedyarov who
handled it uh better a lot of exciting
chess and nepo is pretty much surging
right now taking advantage of the fact
that the people at the top are battling
each other and stealing points from each
other wesley so on at the same time look
at him he's
like he's happy five in a row give me
the next guy who's next
take a ticket who's next right i just
wanted to bring uh because it goes by so
fast uh the the game between magnus
carlson and wesley so because you
pointed out right here in at this moment
uh you're you
you put your pawns on d4 and e4 you have
this beautiful central pawn
it's supported by a pawn on c3 and
whenever you take
you're always automatically supposed to
recapture that that's the feeling yeah
right and then you keep and then then
the game would have probably continued
for example d5
knight e4 and you play i don't know
bishop e3 is a move maybe bishop c2
maybe rookie one and you play but what
happened in the game and i think you
said it very well christian after knight
takes d4 knight takes e6 it seemed like
wesley understood
this position better than the world
champion and with this move queen c7
he sees this initiative
uh and it just simply
from here on out every move that wesley
made
and look at the time right now magnus
with four minutes and 33 seconds wesley
with three minutes and 53 make a couple
more moves okay
two minutes and 51. i spent almost two
minutes on this move king to h2 awkward
move to have to make which probably just
leads to a much worse position queen e2
and then he had to play queenie one at
this point right he spent four minutes
on three moves
he losing 50 seconds on the clock
and then suddenly after h5
this is it this is it and again this
move too bishop the should be
really nice and it's sort of like the
x-ray all the way down the board to the
h2 square
threatening with checkmate and
that was the theme we're threatening
checkmate on h2 this knight is hanging
and uh
away went a very impressive game by uh
wesley i must say just
control and
great stuff so uh with two minutes uh to
go before the start of play we also want
to say that
thank you for joining us of course but
we also enjoy
uh any questions you might have of the
panel i personally
am still coming no but i'm still coming
to grips with this whole magnus carlson
i'm not defending my uh title get over
it
how do i say
my whole career
was kind of impacted by bobby fischer
my whole career
i literally for two decades traveled the
world and wherever i went around the
world the number one question could we
do an interview i go yeah and what's
your first question what happened to
bobby fisher
i mean i was forever being asked this uh
question and i think
a lot of the players today will be asked
in the future
why didn't magnus defend this title yeah
what was the reason what was the yeah
you you provide them with the reason
they asked
yeah but what's the real reason that's
the real reason how about yourselves uh
miro you come to terms um yeah i sort of
did but yeah as we're still having
discussion every day
what's gonna happen how it's to look and
that's say the world championship match
which is a brand itself perhaps the only
brand between chess competitions it
doesn't matter where it's held it's
going to get some recognition but still
world championship with and without
magnus are two different events no no no
question about it i feel
that that says
for sponsor uh
and as we see our marquee match up
wesley so with the white pieces against
jordan van pers jump right in christian
you've come to grips or it's just
i'm starting to yeah i'm i'm slowly
starting to now uh you have to
understand that magnus's goal was always
to be the highest rated player in the
world
even before becoming the world champion
this is what he was mentioning in his
interviews this was what he was focused
on before facing and uh taking down
anand in their 2013 match he wanted to
be the highest rated player in the world
that is still his goal compared to bobby
fisher he's not disappearing he's not
going out of the chess world he's just
simply not going to play the world
championship match and of course that
loses some prestige the world
championship match nevertheless that
also puts a target on magnus right now
everybody is going to try to take him
down everybody's going to be like you
don't want to be the world champion okay
you don't have that aura anymore and i'm
going to try to take you down and we do
have uh blastoff in this fourth round as
we see a karo khan on the board knight
c3 i always thought the knight d2 by the
way was the most precise move on move
three
knight f6 knight of six and take with
the e pawn i remember magnus doing it a
couple of times so
a favorite of uh arena crush 1966 knight
that's a tricky move yeah knight c7
especially against the bishop on e3
because you've already committed bishop
takes a6 would have been met by queen a5
chapter 5
by the way you're not
ruining
black's pawn structure with the move
bishop uh takes a6
bishop f4
bit pardon me bishop to z6 controlling
that foursquare
for just that moment and f45
definitely again the bishop on e3
makes a very attractive target
okay the pawns targeted
well g6 would be kind of a fundamental
way of determining it but maybe you're
looking at f6 perhaps
i think queen s6 is an easier move to
play
uh
than g6 just because you're getting
ready to cast along potentially also
right right
uh
usually when white starts to cast along
in these variations you're also going to
have six on the board yeah you also
don't want to occupy the square too
early because bishop to e6 takes a2 is
actually a really a real pawn you can
grab yeah yes
bishop a3 can be made you know uh
we have bishop f4 on the board all right
bishop f4
okay so bishop e3 to f4
uh
he's playing another
uh king's gambit
king's gambit yes from nepo napo neville
ah
this one yeah i'll check this one later
we will check it later uh what's that
pawn sacrifice
six take on f5 yeah at the end pardon me
rook on e8 at the end do you win a pawn
but you're killing he's still stuck in
the center
but is it upon uh we can
no
no says
like
let's chill not my kind of a pawn yeah
yeah not my cup of tea uh rookie eight
yeah but then i i know that the night
still then the night is still in now
it's still hanging right
rookie eight and you basically forced me
to take on d6 right because rookie two
is he's a threat exactly
and he has done it
it's funny uh this knight on e2
is a little bit awkward you don't really
want to take
whoa
yes if you take the queen
d7
but isn't that isn't this just a much
better position for white
um like let's just exchange everything
chop uh the major pieces on the e file
and just play this end game with what i
think it's almost upon up
that's
yeah
it's
it's not so cut and dry i know what
you're saying you you feel like hey look
i've got the majority yeah that is a
really really a fine majority but
you'd be surprised the those pawns get
blocked yeah pretty nicely that's one
h4 okay i understand that almost
encourages it's a bit surprisingly this
move h4 exactly why not h6 and g5 of
course
you understand why if black plays the
move h5 that solidifies and cements the
pawn structure as it is gives white the
advantage queen to d6 but we still have
this h6 g5 in the pocket right now right
well it's at a certain moment yeah i
mean you eventually do come around to
the idea
that you know what i do have him oops
sorry the bishop comes to c4 the queen
goes to b3 i do have a majority no queen
to d2
so he wants to control
all the dark squares in the position
right or maybe he wants to just exchange
the pieces knight e6 yeah i actually
thought about this but with the queen on
f6 because it turns out that if you
trade only six bishop takes right yeah
uh perch said this structure is not that
easy to break through to begin all right
yeah you're you're kind of a
sort of half an extra pawn right in a
way
in a way yeah but
black is super solid yeah f4 is always
disturbing and so on so knight takes
rook takes says
okay
for bishop to c4 which headed towards
the scenario that christian was
describing that white will try to
exchange as many things as possible
exactly and now perhaps rook to e4 right
yeah rook to e4 is something you
let's say let's make a draw consider
doing no no
that's passive
i find that move a little excessively
passive actually
okay now the idea is if you do try to
chop everything on the e file right now
after root two e8 root three root three
one we exchange on e1 and then go f4
that's why wesley goes for h585
h5
uh
something about this diagonal i would
probably try to encourage
white to play the move h6 if you want to
play the move h6
uh that's on you i like you and he has
done it i like it alpha zero uh h6 you
don't have a game
how about f6 guys i know it sounds
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're not yet getting to this that uh
no i'm very serious because g5 king g6
is well how about rookie fire okay
that might be a problem this looks
terrible why didn't no
no what did you do
what did he do king on f8 would have
been much quieter you know what the
problem is right now i'm threatening g4
uh g4 g5 it's a beautiful beautiful
check by the way uh i don't know if he's
looking at what i do think he's
threatening is rook e1 and just yeah
rookie wanted police command of the
of the okay king f6 was he was there oh
come on i mean you don't have a choice
now g5 is what you have to do g5 g5 to
three
going from the other side as well this
looks like it
looks like well it looks lost
we just suicide our ourselves yeah so
king of six was a little bit
over optimistic
and for jordan and he was forgiven
his only child so you've um you've
called the previous move kind of
excessively passive
yeah
by the way he didn't play f4
he played rookie one which yeah
well actually i'm not that pessimistic
anymore well i mean unless something
falls immediately i i
was a bit slow i fear that that
something may fall immediately g4
your f4 was much stronger yeah just like
yeah f4 i think would have done it but
g4 now g4 maybe i can take on h6
you take on h6 even though you take on
f7 at that point yeah i don't like that
i don't think i want to accept that
g4
what if i go f4 well
if i start with f4 then mirror says f6
and no no off kg4 after europe oh g4 and
play f6 no
because
that something
well
hold on i should d3 kh6 bishop f5 is his
idea that's like pretty straightforward
so what does he have oh after f6 bishop
takes f5 correct and he's done it
but that was what not what he
anticipated doing when he played
can i go with f4 right now for stem
thing
it's really even the
queen checkmate at the end you hide the
king to f8 but
then i take on e5 that's a crazy game
but
it is it is i think he goes for it f4
2 is coming clearing the second rank for
the queen and at the same time
f4 takes e5 with the king on f8
will open up the f-file so this whole
h2 uh we played g7 right here right now
which one king of g7
yeah
queen h2 h6 queen h5 and he's still
getting there and now after queen h5
i'll take the rook and then g6
but then i have rook to e7
no he takes the qui if queen h5 we take
on e5
takes e5
just to be clear f6 takes e5 and g6 is
protected by the queen but then they
take the f pawn
on e5 with the f4
captures the bishop yes yes yes that's a
place
has made a draw his first draw
in quite some time he's been on a
very hot streak
has nepo and the move f6
by
captures sculptures amazingly
he has okay right at the ship
no
no i'm not sure about the bishop here
not that easy anymore well yeah like
bishop f7 and i would be
starting
thinking about playing for a win with
black right right but now queen is
threatening to come out 26.
queen e6 is queen e6
queen e4 queen e4 is there a checkmate
though i mean i understand you have some
checks
i always look at him he's asking his
question just blew it up he's asking the
questions that king is going to d8
your
is
well just a moment because bishop bishop
g6 but yeah but you i don't think you
ever check made this king bishop e6
you're a bishop e6 and you can't control
all the
light bishop b8 i mean if anything okay
by the way how are we doing on time
right
20 seconds for wesley and 49 foreign my
boy
king d8 jordan is right yes and he's
running his pawn up you're right what's
the brilliant king f6 you have to go
king g2 right now f5 queen g5 that's the
only way to corral that pawn right now
and it's time to just
ooh jordan d5 trying to seize the moment
now queen to c6 is a sighting after
queen to e3
yeah so that was the point d5 and he
captures and that's an extra spawn
ism queen e5 just
winning quickly
because
it's an extra pawn right
and i don't think you have the ten piece
why is that queen of five i go king
queen five
yeah must be winning it is winning you
just just stand with the king on e6 and
f6 right you don't need he's done yeah
but no i go to f5
that's that's the question and then you
go to our five four and you play c4 i
don't think you have the ten pieces oh
no
a6
a6 oh you do have the temperature a6 i
want to play b5 no b3
a3 so now b5 b3
b5 b3
b5 b3 a5 question mark exclamation mark
and maybe you have to go for it i know
the a5 is if a5 is silly in fact i mean
the square before a b force clever right
because now if you take that
he's done it but now
c5 check
but yeah but this got to be amazing no
it it's not it's not winning i i'm not
sure it's not winning because king king
if wesley saves this wesley's savings
remarkable
wesley was checking this
but that that's this is winning
it is yeah he's just on time yesterday i
mean it's so exciting now this is this
is easy
right this is easy you just
yeah just go there wow
finally
uh somebody gets uh and jordan takes the
lead right now service announcement
magnus carson loses his name magnus
carson loses his game to linear
dominguez
wow that's a second
in a row
yeah and two in a row for dominguez as
well
wow
uh what surprises me is that magnus is
actually setting up his pieces
i mean i would be furious you'd be out
the door huh
i'm sorry uh and what did mbl do in this
uh what did we
was it another friendly draw like we saw
in the rapid game
like crazy people throwing pieces at
each other
ridiculous and theo versus faruja draw
uh and jan made a draw and somebody said
in a king's gambit
with knight f6 well that's somebody's me
that was you
uh this
like any king's gambit that i'm aware of
i guess mommy the aarov knew this line
with knight f6 knight g5 94 and knight
g5 forcing this end game wow
uh does this even have a name everything
has a name in chat but what would you in
king's gambit especially i think because
of the 18th 17th and 18th century
somebody has played this for the first
time
but uh what what is it called
no idea to be honest i mean this might
have six move never occurred i i i can
tell you it is called it is called let's
see
king's gambit declined
what a year
i could have told you that without even
declining the petrov's defense a petrov
defense petrol
uh
you know uh we have these in chess
periodically these trivial pursuit
nights right where you have all of these
crazy questions
uh if i said to you name me two lines of
the petrov
after you get
the russian defense the petrov
you don't know anything else you know i
didn't know there was a petrov defense
to the king's gambit
wow
and uh let's take a look at our
standings after four rounds uh who's on
top uh well that's for the first time i
wouldn't be able to tell what the
standing is but it's jordan 1 4s back on
top after winning this yeah
controversial game i have to say against
the wesley
but he's at 50 in the in the blitz so
looking good yeah wesley's in second
magnus clear third ali reza and jan
nepal
are tied for the fourth and fifth
because there you see lanier with three
out of four and jan with three and a
half out of four so those are the two
players that are surging magnus carlson
started with two wins followed up with
two losses a very
roller coaster right christian what
other games caught your eye well let's
take a look at how the world champion
went down in this game against dominguez
and i was going through the game and he
actually got outplayed once again at
least in the opening phase and let's
take a look at what happened we got the
rui lopez rook to e1 b5 a4 you have to
defend the rook on 8 otherwise 8 xb5 and
the opening of the a5 comes with
devastating consequences knight to d2
and this is all typical this is still
within theoretical knowledge of these
two players b4 and a typical sacrifice
with b3 as strategical sacrifice after c
takes b3 what you're going to focus on
as black is this key square b4 and try
to lock the bishop behind the pawn chain
and after knight to c6 in order not to
get the bishop blocked you have to
sacrifice the pawn back with the move b4
which dominguez did and he knew that he
has to do this and after that a5 setting
up this weakness on a6 and keep in mind
this weakness because that pawn is going
to fall later on knight to d5 knight
takes f6 bishop takes a6 and at this
point despite the fact that white has an
extra point black still has some
compensation it's not so easy to
get this pawn majority especially this
pawn on a5 going down the port because
the rooks all both the b8 rook which is
going to be transferred to 8 as well as
the upcoming rook from f8 to b8 are
going to put a lot of pressure on a5 and
b2 giving black enough compensation and
let's take a look at what happened
knight to b4 bishop takes b4 and queen
to c3 knight to d2 at this point it did
seem like white is just simply a pawn up
if i manage to set up this knight on c4
which is going to defend both of my
pawns the weaknesses in the position at
the moment a5 and b2 then i'm just
simply going to be winning as white
let's see what happened bishop to d8
setting up the pressure on a5 and now
magnus decided to launch an attack on
the king's side well it makes a lot of
sense a lot of your pieces as white are
set up on the queen side and i still
have this bishop watching both sides of
the board the pawn on a5 as well as
supporting the attack uh watching the
pawn on h4 and supporting the attack
with a g5 queen to e6 g5 finally came on
the board and this was the critical
moment in the game after knight to c4 he
could have taken on g3 take on g3 and
now bishop to f4 setting up this pin and
attacking the pawn on g3 and only after
queen to f2 now that the queen is out of
the way i'm ready to go d5 d5 is upon
sacrifice but i'm opening up the rook
the sixth rank for the rook and after h6
black is going to have a tremendous
attack in the position he did not time
it well he played the move d5 the same
idea you're opening up the sixth rank
and trying to get an attack the problem
is knight to e5 and he missed this move
i'm not forced take on d5 but i can also
take on e5 that's a tempo on the queen
you're losing a lot of material right
now and this is exactly what happened
too many pawns down your mate uh mating
attack is not going anywhere on the
king's side and after that some
mistakes along the way nevertheless
dominguez was never in trouble of losing
his advantage went on to win a smooth
game after that let's see what saris did
against topalov sarish got his first
blitz victory as well and let's take a
look at how that happened we see the
sicilian topalov always bring in the
action in this tournament always
choosing the very aggressive opening
choices e5 opening up the bishop bishop
takes c6 by the way this is still a
theory this exchange sacrifice black has
a lot of initiative with the two bishops
as well as the very powerful center but
it did seem like white managed to
neutralize his attack b3 setting up the
long castle i'm going to give you the
exchange back but i'm going to have this
very powerful complex of pawns and a
potential majority on the queen side in
the end game and this is exactly what
happened rook to g1 rook to g3 you did
not take the exchange that's okay i'll
keep it thank you very much knight to h5
your attack is not going anywhere my
bishop on b2 is defending the queenside
tremendously well and in the meantime
i'm just going to focus on yorking
you're the one as black getting under a
severe attack and after king to h7 queen
to h5 yes gave me that rook as well gave
a saric his first full point in the
blitz section these were the critical
moments in this round a lot of chess
coming your way we're going to go on a
short break and we'll be back shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the croatia zagreb
rapid and blitz we have had four rounds
and now we're ready for round number
five please mero
yeah and the pairs up mamiyara facing
sorry
with nepanishi even though not in the
leading trio but we were
to watch this game very closely right my
key matchup will be this game yeah
because
again
very important of course then one forest
leading and facing dominguez is
something to do who has been playing
very well lanier has three from four
nepo
three and a half and then finally yeah
the paula against wesley saw and wesley
saw just lost his first game in this
event exactly the moment we started
lauding him for being undefeated uh
jordan good for us
plays a remarkable game and there is our
uh
uh
marquee matchup but they look so
chill i mean especially for rouge
oh boy um
what
but don't be fooled i mean the moment
the game starts exactly exactly the
knights come out
it's that awkward moment right before
the start when you don't want to chat
with your opponent you don't want to
look him in the eye too much you just
want to get the game going right exactly
you'll have like 30 seconds a minute and
you want to look relaxed you want to
signal to your opponent hey i'm ready
but at the same time you've got
butterflies in the exactly right
the magnus doesn't seem to have any
there you go there you go let's get
started magnus seems uh bored and angry
at the same time
true that
uh what do we have a tromposky
shrompovsky albany as a well as a
comfortable way of uh avoiding the
grunfeld right trampovsky attack that is
yes they call it an attack
somewhere julian hodgson is saying yeah
that's my opening
he is
very likely to be trans uh transposed
into a queen's gambit no well sometimes
you can go into a kali system with f4
and c3
uh
now that you'd you haven't committed
yourself to c4
right right this looks like where we're
heading
a c2c3
set up
uh very very popular amongst amateurs
because it's the lazy man's approach you
don't have to study those
harrowingly difficult open sicilian
positions
you know you just put your bishop on d3
your
pawn on f4 your knight on f3 yes it's
very healthy system as well right you're
trying to say okay i will not have any
bad pieces
bishop before committing the pawns to
the dark squares right and for me this
move queen c7 is a kind of strange move
it basically suggests
i'm not afraid of bishop takes f6
g takes f6 queen h5
and yet i would be yeah
so you would i would i would put my
knight on d7 or my bishop on e7 first
but um
okay he's basically staking his claim to
the center
he quickly wants to play knight f3 to e5
knights to c6 okay
we expect knight to f3 very quickly
right knight f3
but how how do you break this formation
of whites as black
i am going to get the knight to e5 and
then at some point whenever you on which
you probably will castle short right
that's black well
that's uh the thing that's perhaps given
me thinking this might be our questions
have been answered
if you take with the seaport knight to
b4 is coming he
he captures with the c pawn knight to b4
now if you drop back to b1 i can go
bishop to a6
uh yeah that might be absolutely right
so did he
well wait a minute because there is a
look if i go bishop b1 bishop a6 there
is a queen a4
channel but i can simply just go knight
d7 right
oh yeah
knight c5 there's a queen c1 yeah
very fair but by the way i don't know
ah he's thinking about bishop i should
be five check and then castle short yeah
exactly
i mean
your bishop's not going to e2 there's a
knight c2 so it should be checked
but that allows me to exchange the light
score bishop as you get which is an
improvement
you you get rid of your worst piece for
sure and this bishop on d3 actually is a
very important
attacker i am it disturbs black
tremendously and we take with the knight
and then after shortcast they'll be
queen c2 as well that means that i would
be tempted to make work so you know
something
queen c2 perhaps you can start with
it
no seriously because if anything i think
i'm good on kind of positional play
right i mean i've exchanged the bishop
as he said but i'm somewhat like in
development and if i say play bishop d6
instead then some rook c1 with stampy
and so-and-so i'd be a bit scared and
maybe would try to make winston work
just kind of to simply find to an end
game but yeah
he played bishop d6 by the way very very
quick draw by wrestling topolof and
wesley saw right wesley
having just lost the game and they've
repeated really really quickly early in
the in that game losing his first game
of the tournament of the whole
tournament exactly well roxy won
let's go what took it it was so long to
play that move
that move but faster exactly
95 a3 these moves
kicks the knight back then the knight
has probably don't want to see six i
mean that knight is going to be right
and knight
things are coming with tempo for uh for
black for white so absolutely the knight
on c6 under duress is starting to become
a bit problematic right queen g4 queen
h5 should you ever castle yeah if you
are doing five is the question to secure
your position right now right
uh
because you might get a problematic
knight e7
knight f5 will be a great defense which
makes me
want to take it makes me want to take
but i also look at queen
h52 queen h5 h5 was so attractive
you can okay but what about
taking and then queen to a4
b5 in this case i was looking yeah take
on e7 is good yeah bishop takes and then
i want to provoke b5 but also queen c2
takes takes and just
simple move queen
bishop takes back queen h5 is one thing
that the uv arsenal mentioned quincy ii
or queen a4 b5 queen c2 exactly
i would like to attract the pawn to b5
if simply because i look at my knight
and say what's your job he says well you
give me an outpost
and if i can provoke the move b5 i get
an outpost so queen a4
with the idea of b5 queen c2 i think
99 c6
well that's an outpost if we can keep it
so now bishop to
d6 is probably going to be met by e4
right oh well e4 is this what he's
trying to do okay i think e4 85 and 90
no yeah that's one but if e4 works it's
of course kind of deserves to be played
exactly with the king still stuck in the
center but yeah and he will enable this
possible because of e5 yeah right it's
dreadful but e4 maybe rook c8 rook c8 i
think on defense you take on d5 guard
the knight he goes for it and then go
with a check yeah e4 played e4 looks
like a very strong move that some people
prefer to play in move one
that was the punchline
timing is important not only in bank
robberies but in chess
and you have a lot of experience a lot
of experience
wanted in 25 states you'd be surprised
e4 uh
best buy test
yeah he doesn't like it he doesn't like
it well the problem is after castle i go
wait a second e5 then he
he wants to go rook to c8 after e5
exactly
by the way
very clever move queen f3
anticipating that if you take there's
going to be some tactics
on this diagonal oh those are it's going
to hurt those are naughty
yes yeah i think oh by the way queen to
f3 just looks
busted yeah green f3 is very strong
very strong move uh
times
two minutes for napo two minutes and 16
seconds and one minute and 26 seconds
for furusa
one minute but putting a lot of pressure
right now on nepal
absolutely
in
russia uh
nepo has a great reputation as a blitzer
are they uh
uh
who would uh
who would be his strong whoa
bishop
what is that but if i just take d5 pawn
what's with what's that f6 at the end of
the day
no i'm not sure he has to go knight of
six at the end
because 97 is a problem right
and you cannot take on d4 because i just
simply take it with a queen oh yes so
that's his point i take d5 knight f6
and then
going back to f3 right
six and you were pawn down but at least
kind of survive didn't lose immediately
i'm not so sure because that pawn goes
to d5 that knight remains on the board
what a powerful
knight on c6 also after bishop d6 how do
you defend after knights okay
much better move than what we were
looking at that any bishop retreats
would have just been terrible rook c8
keeps black in the game
for now for now right now it's ali raza
who's playing for two results right
okay so
you can take the p6 and transition into
the end game well that's a check that's
a check four wait a second knight
oh i like that move knight c4 has ideas
of knight a5 if you take as well as
knight e5 and c6 going to c7 queen c7
returning the favor d4 now if you take
on c5 i'm going to go 95 first and then
take on c5 creating a password very nice
but you have to
take it otherwise it's just a pawn down
for goodness right and now we're going
straight into that line you can go rook
to a6 and say that if you do take with
the pawn create pass pawn i will take on
a3 but i will not because the queen on
f3 actually protects that part
you didn't even
give me a chance to re-future
i know i know you were waiting
i know you were waiting
i wanted to show you uh the amazing move
queen f3 takes right
sometimes i catch my own ah
hate that and then i cannot afford to
give you the option to correct me by the
way the capture on c5 by the pawn i
understand
it's a powerful pawn a beauty to be sure
but rook takes would have been a nice
tempo too
and
how quickly he made that decision to
take on c5 know that he had the choice i
mean he's
down to his last 30 seconds
right now again
if you have one for nepo
so something like rook up and rook over
just defending everything
let's see rook c3 that's the move he
prefer to play
okay check
yeah the fact that white has f4 played
is something yeah we've been really
happy with you yeah exactly very like
just simple a but now having said that
sometimes you use you turn this uh
into a virtue right uh ooh did you
really allow c7 but c7 he
apparently has calculated everything
like he gets rook c8
so h3 now so i thought c7 would have
been
securing
a then you're going to have to defend
from from ca from ca yeah
exactly
seven and you'll have to train the
queens
queen g3 i wasn't sure like if you trade
the queens and then king is crumbling he
went back he went he recognized that
the
uh
on c7 is too strong
we have another result yeah we have by
the way uh
jordan against the leadership dominguez
is another
i think time pressure
sneaking up on the players is
nine seconds for firouza 23 and counting
before you really just take that pawn he
didn't play queen d7 he played rook
he won he's trying to infiltrate
is just
one rookie one
he takes another one no we don't believe
this
i'm a fun grubber but that no not the
right he wants to take on h3 if you go
c7
rookie that's a perpetual right there
that's a fourth beautiful
wow beautiful what an escape by nipple
pond grabbers never grabbers league yeah
phone grabbers wow
what a save what do we have left
let's jump to the game of the world
champion between blitz specialist
magnus carlson and mvl what do we have
bishops of opposite color but a passer
a very big passer on the a file
the a file and the h file in fact
i just don't walk okay we
we dropped the f4 pawn as far as the
windows started that one
[Music]
a7 but the ball is not running anywhere
yeah the a7 pawn
stopped by very good point i just
stopped by the rook but stopped
so he's trying to say that yeah
decoy one of your pieces like i'm a
little bit worried there's no mate
for uh
foreign
and look at that
he's inviting f2
h7 is a big one guys
f but you need them if you go after our
give that bishop
that's a chat
yeah rook e8 brilliant you say rooked
way forward
wow
what a game hey look at this magnus is
showing his skills and setting up the
pieces
that last see sequence at the very end
was really confusing we still have one
game left oh excellent i think it's a
game between the arrows
still in progress let's jump sorry i uh
i thought that was the end but no what
do we have oh white is that what's
changed but it seems like it is shocking
white is just winning right exactly
e4 goes to f3 king f3 and it's over and
that's it i'm collecting everything
everything
wow what a round
of changes at the top it seems like
right so since carson wins constantly
must be in the lead
at least surely
uh we'll pick up on that i just wanted
to see
i just wanted to pick up on this game
between magnus and mvl
um
because that sequence at the end really
was remarkable ah there's been a lot of
stuff that was remarkable this game yeah
so you see opposite colors
okay a long time ago and
75.
somehow
going to get to that moment where we
kind of came in
and we sort of thought that wasn't
magnus for choice i mean but
then suddenly
around these parts
it's sort of like
wow
h-pawn was rushing apon was rushing
why did he have to give a check
maybe he didn't have to it's just that
you know low on time you have to do
something
low on time
and this moment
check and
two bridesmaids
king f4 now it's very easy to overlook
that king e3 f2 and rook d1 would be
mate but magnus was alert that's
actually a bad move is it it's a bad
move the easy way out in this position
would have been to just go a8
yes yes yes
and then you're getting another queen
yeah you win the bishop for one queen
and then yeah then you get three you
have a check and then you get another
and actually rook to e8 allows black
back into the game but the solution to
get back in the game is just simply
ridiculous the solution take a look
rook 38 now bishop to c2 is the move uh
bishop c2 and a perpetual if you get a
queen i'm just giving you a perpetual
rook the d1 rook to d2 is it the
perpetual though yeah yeah check here
because you can't go to h3 because of
bishop f5 and you cannot go to f1
because of bishop to d3 followed by f2
oh yeah and this is where you walk into
a mate
wow so rook e8 which was clever enough
to stop the king e3
allowed bishop c2 and perpetual and if
he had queen at once
he would have won uh simpler
[Laughter]
what's our current standings after all
of that crazy uh miss uh miro who's on
top oh yeah i thought magnus caught up
but no the answer is it's jordan one for
rest still leading with
fifty percent interestingly enough
because the other slim lead yeah the the
other guys keep beating each other and
therefore he's getting away with you
know only 50 scored but he keeps the
lead so tie for the second between
magnus carson and wesley saw ali reza
firuja and yami tied for with the fourth
and mbl
kind of slipping away i really expect
kind seriously i expected him to have
certainly better than a minus score
after five rounds
and christian what uh caught your eye in
this crazy round
well let's look at all the other games
as well as the critical point actually
in the game that we were looking at the
one between ali reza and nepo because
after queen to f4 ali reza still has
this still can win this position queen
to d8 was the critical mistake and after
c7 we saw this a very nice pattern
perpetual pattern with rook to h3
followed by queen to f3 but what he
should have understood and of course is
very difficult with 10 seconds on the
clock is that he needs to keep this
queen ready to protect the king he does
that and supports the c pawn and attacks
the rook on a3 with this move queen to
c5 this was the critical move now
unfortunately you can no longer take
because i take you give a check i go to
h2 there's this f2 square which is
protected by the queen you cannot
continue your perpetual checks and if
you do go to f4 then i just simply go
king to g2 you're running out of checks
pretty much so this was the critical
moment ali reza could have taken down
nepomnyashi let's take a look at what
happened in
van forest versus dominguez well this
was actually a game without a lot of
content and a lot of history and let's
take a look at how it developed we see
the petrov and to be honest dominguez
had absolutely no problems equalizing
once again we see this e file open this
is the chopping block we're going to
exchange all the major pieces on it and
this is what happened rook to d8
followed by rook to e8 we're exchanging
the rooks we go into this end game it is
only black who can be better close
center close position and i have the
knight but of course nothing actually
happens because the material is very
limited so this one finished in an easy
draw for both players topolo versus
wesley this one actually finished in
around 30 seconds and let's take a look
at how that happened c4 e5 d5 and then
in this position b4 e4 take on e4 and
the players decided topolo that is
decided because he could have tried to
get away from it unfortunately if you do
try to go queen to d1 which is the only
other move you have in the position most
likely you will just simply be worse
after bishop to f6 the rook doesn't
really have a lot of hiding squares
unfortunately you cannot go to c3 or b2
because after bishop to f6 you actually
lose that rook for nothing so uh this
was just a forced repetition by a wesley
and topalov and let's take a look at
what happened in the other game that we
have not seen we only see uh we only saw
the end of that is the game between
mamedyarov and saric and we had actually
some sort of a groomfeld the delayed
grunfeld waiting for white to commit to
the move g3 and only then play the move
at d5 and this is what we got knight to
f3 take on d5 it did seem like uh black
is just simply going to be okay in this
position you're going to take on d1
we're going to enter this end game
you're going to take on b7 sure you're
going to restore the material balance
but generally this is considered to be
just simply fine for a black if you know
the theory and if you know what you're
going to play and this was played before
he uh played the move castle at this
point and decided to avoid the queen
trade with queen to c4 leaving a couple
more attackers in the position for white
and we got into this end game now the a
pawn is really powerful i'm going to set
it up on a5 or a6 and this pin that i
have with the bishop a7 supported by the
rook on b7 is very powerful and very
controlling you cannot once i put the
pawn on a5 attack it with the bishop or
at least is not as useful because i also
have this attack coming on at the
seventh rank with my rooks doubling on
the seventh rank and the bishop is going
to be tied to the defense of the e7 pawn
so let's take a look at what happened
leave the pawn on a5 get the bishop to
b6 and once again bishop to c3
unfortunately doesn't work because of
rook two d7 he decided to go rook takes
a5 and go into this end game which to be
honest uh it did look like he's very
close to equality right this bishop very
powerful protects the pawn on e7 maybe
you can even go e5 and set up your
blockade like that let's take a look at
how he decided he did put a pawn on e5
and then rook to e to get the rook off
the second rank off its uh active square
and then we got to this position once
again i think black right now has uh a
big chances and very serious chances of
equalizing and making a drop but in fact
it was mamedyarov who managed to trick
his opponent now g5
bishop to g7 and once again now the e7
pawn is a weakness no longer you have
the square to defend both pawns the e5
and e7 i kick that bishop away i'm
transitioning my rook towards the
seventh rank if you do defend the rook
the seventh rank with your rook i'm
going to target the g6 pawn and this is
exactly what he did at one point he was
forced to trade the rooks and this is
just all she wrote because now i can
just simply go f4 king to e2 you take
that that's okay but your bishop is
going to get stuck there and this is
exactly what happened we already saw
this position this is where we moved to
this game and we saw the final moves
very nice game by mamedyarov but once
again it is all about the jordan magnus
and wesley those guys are at the top but
ferugia and nepal also closely behind
this one is going to be a hotly
contested end of uh today's rounds and
uh yeah that's amazing guys uh what did
you see in today's round i i was
mesmerized by that ending i didn't think
that shaq was going to win it but as we
saw he did
shayman as we haven't told you about our
q boutique specials but we will make up
for you right now yeah we will because
yeah but the main reason being yes uh
not
agreeing to wear the t-shirt
okay so today's special is the
granchester
t-shirt limited edition official 2022
edition features okay you can see the
front which is the logo and all the
tourist stop it stops at the back
bucharest versus zagreb and sandler yeah
very very nice and as we come up to our
round six pairings uh the game that uh
i i certainly remember we started the
rapids
with magnus versus nepo
the world championship match well now
we're going to see it in blitz yeah
we'll satan blitz with scholars reversed
so napo will have the white pieces
against magnus carlsen and yeah that's
the match that magnus didn't want to
happen
we will force him to play yeah so saric
faces wesley so dominguez against the
follow-up mvl will have white against
jordan one force i'll back up uh marquee
matchup yeah and mommy giroff will play
against ferruja the whatever i check
what 140 has the black pieces i mean is
it fair i mean no no
no but uh this nepo versus magnus
carlson match uh
i i mean it's just such a
iconic uh
thing now uh whenever these guys are
going to be playing
uh whether it be here in st louis for
the sink field cup or anywhere people
are going to say hey this was the match
that never took place which was the case
with fabian magnus if you remember yes i
think they've played the last game
before the match at least classic last
classical game here in saint louis back
in whatever it was 2018 yeah exactly
well okay uh
first impressive
uh
first impressions of the grand chess
store standings are as follows
uh here we have uh after
the warsaw in bucharest and going into
the
zagreb
after two stops is
where we stand here yeah so it's level
navronian leading yeah wes followed by
wesley so lebron and fabiano yeah
obviously not present here so
wesley saw who can improve his gct score
in
zagreb very much so and again the grand
chess tour at the end they have this
very nice pool of prizes
including a hundred thousand for the top
and i believe it goes like 50 25. so
uh
scoring those grand chess tour points
very important
yeah uh magnus is not on the list of
people's scoring gcct points because
he's a wild card
yeah interestingly multi-tour
participant right well exactly uh it's
kind of interesting it's when we were
making the grand chess tour list and of
course we want magnus always to play at
that point it wasn't clear
that he wasn't going to be playing a
world championship match
and
well ali farouja was not the winner of
the candidates and magnus said i'm not
playing well why didn't you plan the
tour in that case you know like we could
have really enjoyed having you um
okay uh
well i wanted to ask uh impressions
after uh five blitz games
games
is is really feeling
napo um
i wanted to say carlson but then i
recall this only game he lost oh no he
didn't lose he lost too yeah yeah it was
two victories and two losses and uh yeah
there you see
who's performing well in the blitz
yeah
exactly here is performing quite well
the problem is he did pretty poorly in
the rapid yes
precisely so so he only
have ten and a half points right now
that's
that's a considerable gap yeah that's
that's a big gap
right magnus
he's definitely not himself nevertheless
he's still scoring important victories
uh that's three out of five games up to
this point not that bad
for me the surprise is jordan van forest
not the fact that he's in first place
power too and i love it love it love it
but normally when you only have 50
after five rounds in the blitz
uh you're not going to be leading you
know you need to have at least a plus in
both the rapids and the blitz because
somebody's going to be
outperforming crazy there you see before
the game uh mvl and
jordi uh
really enjoying the moment
and perhaps yasa the reason he's leading
with 50 in blades that nobody's crushing
it so you could argue nep was crushing
the blitz with four out of five but yeah
he did really bad in rapids
as well right i mean the the guys who
are crushing it in the blitz
uh section so far uh started way behind
the leaders okay these two uh customers
know each other quite yeah yeah
one of jan's last chance is to play
against magnus right
and i see uh
nepo is smirking
now trying to tempt magnus potentially
reply with a smirk of his own magnus
says no
i'm here for business
um business is business
as the warner brothers
said
and i think this will be our marquee
matchup of the round
you can't avoid this one no
and is what is that one nepal shirt is
that a unicorn is that a bird what is it
it's superman
[Laughter]
i had wanted to ask in russia nepo
who's nepo's fiercest blitz rival would
it be krishuk or it's not just hard to
tell because you have this new
generation of players like artemia for
instance right so nepo is always
recognized as one of the strongest but
you you can't really
put his uh junior
uh crown good guys yeah yeah grisham is
obviously known for being very very
strong right
and once again we see nebo essaying uh
this king's indiana
however you want to call it
uh d4 reverse groom fell over anybody
beautiful
that's what i usually do yes that's your
choice yes it's definitely my choice c2
c4 has oftentimes been my choice in this
position and castle allowing e5 c
consoles e5 and then c4 yeah that that's
playable
and d5
okay uh
you can get into trouble very very
easily with black this move queen a4
threatens obviously knight e5
and uh
if you play bishop dc c7 queen b agree
three's the move
whoa bishop to d6 is it playable at all
that is the best move in the position
yes and it is actually
there was a game between caruana and
nepo with the black pieces so maybe he's
drawing some inspiration from them well
what them by the way for a very visual
move right i mean still following that
game caruana versus nepo the one move
you think you've stopped by putting your
pawns on c5 and e5 and look at the world
champion magnus
gripping his head like what have i done
i've walked into something i'm trying to
remember a theory right now
and how did that game that you cited go
after d4 christian let's take a look uh
e takes d4
so i'm going to take one d on the board
right now and then i'm going to take on
d4 that is what he did and then i have a
and then took on d4 and then we just saw
ambush that exchange
of knights and then short castle for
black
inviting bishop takes c6 and so on yes
right
and uh black seems to have enough
compensation for the last pawn in that
position agreed with the two bishops
here well i don't really have a choice
do i beside after
other than knight takes d4 yeah he
doesn't know it and he is i don't have
that much liberty you have to win your
pawn back and also you have to take
otherwise knight takes e6 is
rather unpleasant and now castle
sacrificing a pawn
is what we expect that was played by
nemo uh now there's also the move queen
to b6 just simply try to defend the pawn
that's an option as well
i see the question is what type of
position do you want to play do you want
to give up the pawn and play for the
initiative or do you want to potentially
defend a strategically inferior position
of the community so personally being the
aggressive
player that i am i would sacrifice upon
and
we all expected this yeah of course
of course you're known for your fearless
fearless play yeah absolutely
dignity dignity dignity uh at all times
that's been my motto
rook d1 bishop c5 that would be a funny
so probably you have to stay out of the
d file
but bishop c5 is not the end right no
you would have it
yeah you you may have to give up but
it's not only bishop to c5 but i think
also bishop be fine if i was bishop
might be a bit more problematic that's
great a4 though
okay so it's a little bit
scary i understand that rook d1 bishop
c5 oops excuse me rook d1
bishop c5
queen a4
would allow queen f6 and
f6 and yeah maybe there's a question f4
then yeah the problem with bishop to uh
i do take on d8 and then i go knight c3
and i think that allows me to develop
all my pieces okay
bishop e5 might be a bit more
problematic okay
and very
interestingly rook e1 came
best movie in the position rook to ba
quickly knight c3
it's all about
utilizing
this
bishop
getting some kind of attack on the
king's side what he so far he's not
getting
anywhere
yeah yeah queen e7
okay so bishop f4 will return b2
but
even then white might be better
agreed exchange the bishops rook takes
b2 maybe go rook b1
then try to trade this active rook of
blacks and knight e4 bishop e3
those seem to be the alternatives yeah
i just feel like b3 is too slow yeah it
does seem bishop's g5 bishop g5 okay
okay i like this one
trying to provoke f6
queen e6 well then i've got the move the
developing move bishop g5
for tempo for free yeah but then once
again b2
is hanging
still problems to for for both players
christian no absolutely absolutely this
position is very complex black still has
some initiative left in the position you
still have a lot of weaknesses to tend
to but if you manage to stabilize as
wide well that's going to be a point
good exactly bishop f4 so maybe not even
transposing now rook takes b2 and
restoring material balance in the
position yeah we could have had this
position with the queen on e7 instead uh
nepa felt it was
useful to lure the queen to e6 maybe
knight f3
knight knight no
d1 just uh
intimating he's ready to post up at
least from a practical perspective it
does feel like black has solved most of
his issues
in this game maybe even taking over the
initiative right now with the material
balance restored still not so clear
because i i'm i'm eyeballing rook d6
and rook d6 if you if you if i force you
back there's always the possibility of
g3 g4 when the bishop could be
okay so i have a couple of tasks yes at
hand for black i need to make a loop for
my king first yep and then try to put
some pressure on the b file so let's
start with h6 h6 would be met by rook to
d6 okay so you go rook to d6 yes i do
then i go queen to e7
are you going to take on c6 why do the
answers
yes
and queen to b7 now you're on the
diagonal of g2 exactly i'll go queen to
c7 inviting the queen train
he invited the queen trade okay that's
an interesting one
um
that gives me the chance to trade queens
and maybe
uh liberate my king when i need to with
that but from a strategical perspective
it does make sense because we know uh
that trading queens probably will favor
black on some degree right the
cooperation between the rooks and the
bishop is better than rooks and knight
supposedly
one uh king f8 not even bothering to
make a lifting he's dead it's a kind of
seven yeah but that's a good one right
exactly i'm thinking white's king
f3 king f2
also needs a little liberation okay
by the way the knight is actually knight
is a powerful piece fabulously defending
e2 a2
and blockading work to c7 most likely
coming on the board and we've seen it
again f3 king f2 would be
my
maybe so who do you guys prefer in this
position
i have a slight preference for y really
slight
preference for y yeah i mean as long as
the knight is stable on c3 that's it
yeah
it's unclear how black will be able to
push it away exactly and then it guards
everything it stops the c
yeah blocks physically the c pawn from
running further right it protects two
weaknesses that white has right the
other thing that's kind of interesting
it's a little bit trappy
uh you have a passport
when you push it to c4
your bishop actually ends up kind of
like
why did you do that to me and i think
it's an it's uh
it's testing that magnus was not anxious
to push respond to c4 but instead to
keep the square c4 available for his
bishop oh that's quite interesting
repeating the moves
and
king g7 now magnus said no no no let's
play on
even though objectively we think that
yeah maybe why should have some reason
but by the way can i i can probably
force the repetition or at least attempt
a repetition once again with knight b5
knight b5 rook b7 knight c3
true and then you'll be attacked but i
was just
can i
no you can't but i think on a2 right a2
is hanging as well and perhaps that's
not the best version for how about rook
b7
rook e7 you have some cheapos
i don't know
uh rook c5 yeah
yes
hanging yeah happy that's easy that's
probably better for black times please
uh mural what are we looking at in terms
of the chess class roughly one minute
for both sides for both sides yeah yeah
yeah it costs a little bit below one
minute i see
so rook to b7 of course to c3 might be
might be
let's see big decision for magnus
dropping down to his last 30 seconds
i mean if he was really
on
rook d7 the one move we really didn't
consider so much so
now you've got to take on a2 who takes
c5 rook rook to d2 would be met my
knight c3 bishop takes a2 bishop
so now wait a second rook a7 rook takes
b5 he's that's a nice uh trap oh
and if you take with the knight and rook
d2 comes right so
knight to c3 was played followed by
bishop to e6 but nicely done right rook
a3 rook a5
rook
a5 i think is on tap for
roxanna
well he can also invite the trader
experience
for you
yeah he's done it
bishop
three wait a second can we just take the
pawn on it
but how bad is this now well it's a pawn
as well as the previous position
oh how do we fight
oh
that was howler where the bishops go in
bishop
bishop basically one of bishop a6
there was a button now there's another
one
right
yeah
no there's actually no one that was
exceptionally tricky though yeah
sometimes those
shorter sign controls ambitions i mean i
see all of these 2800s as being
incredibly resourceful
in absolutely ridiculous positions they
find oh that's a beautiful five five oh
but now he's in a pin yeah c5 and he
avoids the trade of rooks for now but
yeah how long can you wait with by the
way rook f5 and
king ga by the way the leader of
amforest wins his game against mvo ooh
on forest
taking down one of our blitz specialists
i'm really expecting rook f5 to
wait a second yes now you can't even
move the knight because he trades on a5
bishop t5 and stops the unite from it
it's just a winning position exactly to
suji on the night domination of the
night
and look at this h4
getting closer and closer to a win did
he just forget about his clock did he
just play h4 without pressing the clock
did he really i think so
i once saw in a world championship match
uh gary kasparov for getting depresses
clown and nepo actually reminded him hey
you have to press the clock
my second thing five seconds for the
world champion oh
yeah but now rook d2 is made he's about
to win
d2 h3 followed by h3
there's no check on it there is no check
on a4 yes sir this is it and a windfall
magnus is very important you said
jordan that one and the other games are
let me just switch over
shaq
and farrugia
i've got uh the sh shack
game for ruja
and saric against wesley he's also still
this looks like this guy i think versus
wesley we have to move to that one
because there's a lot of consequences on
the board oh whoa
there's a couple of queens there's also
an extra bishop but the kings is
this king the king is coming
yeah wait a second uh no but wesley just
won right wesley
with the extra piece must be winning to
d3 followed by bishop to d4 no bishop to
f bishop f6 okay not the most obvious to
be honest well just protect the bishop
the problem is there is also another
pawn coming there's that pawn on oh
that's a nasty move beautiful game by
wesley he needed this victory he
certainly did in touch with the leaders
and this indeed was a draw
and for jordan van porris the surreal
experience of continues right right
right it's all going
wonderfully right well
as he continues unexpectedly to lead the
tournament yeah we surely have to check
what has happened in his game against
them
for certainly and
shaq farrugia draw magnus loses the most
pardon me magnus wins
so uh still maintains a half a point
yeah you would think you won against
nepal with black come on i mean when is
this
actually leading yeah give him an extra
quarter of a point there lots of
decisive games once again uh in this
round ivan sarich
losing
with why he's just awesome so
a lot of people winning with black
pieces right unlike classical and rapid
here well the opening preparation is
important but you don't have
such uh you know such an importance of a
color because you might have a good
position but running low on time and you
can easily explain
interestingly enough christian in that
game that was just played between nepo
and um magnus we reached a moment in the
game we said
i'd rather be white i'd rather be white
nobody said i'd rather be black and yet
it was magnus winning with the black
pieces i felt that the cooperation
between the rooks and the bishop will be
better nevertheless that nikon c3 was so
powerful right right it was keeping nice
control of the position up until he
missed bishop takes c2
that was the critical moment once you
miss bishop take c2 and you have to play
against uh the a pawn you're just simply
going to be lost in nine out of ten
especially in the practical situation in
the blitz game against the world
champion who can and we've seen how
precise is when it comes to those type
of conversions now let's take a look at
what happened in the mvl van forest
because i was going through the game at
the beginning and it did seem like mvl
was just building up an attack out of
the opening
this was the end game that we ended up
in uh the beginning was an english setup
by uh mvl maybe taking advantage or uh
trying to take control the way madness
did against jordan we remember jordan
did lose yesterday in the rapid
match against magnus pretty much out of
the opening in an english setup and this
is exactly what nvr was gunning for as
well and he did get an advantage with
this move knight to a3 very nice
enterprising idea allowing black to
damage white spawn structure but at the
same time get two bishops especially
that dark square bishop which is going
to be damaging on the long diagonal and
let's take a look at how the game
progressed take on c4 we ended ended up
in this end game
and uh it did seem like despite the fact
that the material is even the position
is open and i have two bishops you have
two knights they're cutting the board in
half so there's definitely some pressure
coming from white's perspective bishop
to f3 f6
you look at this end game and you don't
think that white can ever lose it right
so how did it happen knight rook to d6
bishop to d1 i really like this
transition to a b3 putting some pressure
on the black king king to g7 and we got
to this position
this was the critical moment guys after
a4 knight to d6 still white is on top
still white has the advantage but after
bishop d5 you're starting to weaken your
pawn structure and i found a way
systematically to get my knights to a
position where i can attack the pawn on
a4 and force you to give up one of your
bishops with the move bishop to b3
because of course a5 i just simply take
with the other knight so after bishop to
b3 once i eliminate one of the bishops
now it is black who is playing for a
victory because i have a lot of
weaknesses that i can target
specifically the weaknesses on the queen
side and my king is ready to invade via
the queen the king side and this is
exactly what happened king to h5 bishop
to f6 this seems to have been the
critical mistake once i plant the king
to g4 and you are supposed not to allow
me to do that with the move king to f3
this was the best move but at the same
time once you see this knight jumping
around knight to a5 uh creating some
more weaknesses in your position you
start feeling quite uncomfortable with
white so bishop to f6 king to g4 once i
control and keep connection with the
pawn on f4 also ready to play the move
king to h3 this is just winning uh a
technical win for black at this point h4
knight to b4 and actually i think he
just pretty much resigned or lost on
time flagged mvl that is after knight to
b4 the game pretty much was over so big
win for van forest this is undoubtedly
one of his most important uh victories
of today with the back pieces against a
blitz expert now let's take a look at
what happened in saraj vs wesley
e4e5 and this one seemed innocuous at
the beginning as well but wesley came
with this novel idea knight to e7
allowing white to damage the pawn
structure on the king side at the same
time once again it's a trade-off you're
giving me your dark square bishop you
get the better structure in return and i
have a lot of dynamic play with black
pieces at some point i'm going to go d5
f5 i'm putting a lot of pressure and he
goes for castle castle after your upon
structure got damaged on the king side
like this this doesn't feel like the
right choice nevertheless it did seem
like wesley perhaps was aware of what he
was doing only uh well actually four
minutes and 39 seconds at this point so
he wasn't spending as much time against
four minutes and 21 seconds for ivan
sarich d6 and then we got into at this
position knight to f3
a lot of things have changed it still
felt like white is just simply better
and cannot lose this position opposite
color bishops i'm getting the queen to
e4 it feels like i have a lot of control
with the white pieces so where did he
lose that control well let's take a look
a lot of exchanges have happened still
white has absolutely no problems and
should not be losing this position but
slowly slowly
well he got a pawn queen takes h4 queen
takes h4 bishop to e1 give me that c3
pawn
let me create this passer as well and
unfortunately you're starting to be in
some sort of danger right now because my
king is running and it's going to be a
race i'm going to get this king on uh
this side you're going to try to promote
your h pawn let's see who's first
king to g4 king to d6 king to f3 this
was a mistake f6 he was supposed to play
the move f6 to try to invade via f5 with
the king as well as ideas of bishop to
g6 at times and create another passer
very very difficult position to handle
with only seconds on the clock king to
e4 king to c5 king to d3 king to b4 just
simply too passive right now and the
critical mistake was this move king to c
to what he was supposed to understand in
the position was that you cannot touch
with black pieces the pawn on c4 once
you take on c4 i have this check on a2
then i'm going to pick up the pawn on f7
so the best move in the position was
king to e4 now if you try to come to b3
and create something on this side well
too bad i have my own pawns as well and
i'm going to go c5 you take i go b6 and
with the king on e4 you cannot open the
action of the bishop on f4 with the move
e4 to catch that pawn so unfortunately
you're not in time he did not understand
that he played the move king to c to two
passive that just gives me after bishop
g5 bishop a2 king to c5 i'm going to
pick up this pawn create another passer
in the position and that's just simply
going to be all she wrote
king to d6 bishop to g7 it seems like
actually this was a mistake as well for
black let's see where that big mistake
was a3 apparently this was a mistake f6
was the winning move
well uh paint me confused because i'm
not 100 sure why this move is the
winning move it does seem that after
king to f5 king to d4 it's almost a zeus
one once you play the move a3 you allow
me to have this extra square bishop to
b3 this is not uh something that is easy
to understand with only once again
seconds on the clock so where was
white's mistake in the position bishop
to h8 king to f5 king to c5
f5
take on f5 king to d4 and now bishop to
b1 this was the mistake bishop to b3 was
the right move
definitely not an easy move to make and
after bishop to b1 the other pawn is
going down the board and we got into the
end game that we saw on the board with
an extra piece for wesley and the
victory quite an important and uh pretty
much grinded out victory for wesley to
stay within contention from the leaders
thank you christian after a very
topsy-turvy
round of five these are our standings
miro yeah still the leader is the same
as if we would not play today's
secretary today's blitz right jordan one
forest is in the lead magnus carlsen and
wesley so closely following him
and uh well after all of those rounds
we're going to take a very short break
as we'll be bringing you round seven see
on the other side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and our pairings for around seven nero
do the honors please yes only three
three games to play today and in round
seven we have first against saric
carlson facing mommy yara to paolo
against mvl a wesley saw against
dominguez but the game will be
concentrated the most on is one forest
the leader with white against jan
nepomnichi
wow they're storming off the gates yeah
and they're off uh yeah and that's a
patch of defense and uh well did we pick
a plan b yeah because this might be way
not yet not yet yeah but there is a
potential right like knight d2 knight
takes d2 also knight c3 uh but knight d2
the other one must be magnus versus
mommy the arrow right we have a plan b
knight takes queen takes you up queen to
d7 and this is like you know one of
those uh
rookie one
whoa but bishop b5
is an attempt to uh spice it up seven
was queen d7 such a clever move because
you are invited to five right you're
really inviting 95 95 queen to d6 and
how do you continue after that well just
to double up the pawns and say but
is the question yeah well i'm
accomplishing some kind of inbound
there's also there is also an attempt to
take on c6 twice i don't know if it's
too risky wait what
e7 is happening there's a rook on here a
seven is hanging at the end you'll take
c2 and this structure is opposite called
bishops like you take with the bishop
perhaps then white plays b3 or something
no that one looks good my rook will at
the end of the day be on the seventh
rank and i can also take on c7 right i'm
afraid that if we we swap and my rook
goes to e7 he'll play rookie eight and
he'll invite
bishops of opposite color so if i
take and take and
take
then queen takes
rook takes root thanks you don't take on
c2 rather you just
challenge the here we go okay we'll see
it so knight takes pawn takes
bishop three so he keeps
so he understood that bishop c6
queen c6 rook e7 rookie eight
perhaps that wasn't always compensation
i think it was compensation because if
you do try to hold on to your opponent
with c3 queen to c4 or queen to p5 is
coming in rook to e2 is very damaging
clear clear but this move bishop d3 is
inviting bishop takes d3
queen takes d3 and uh bishop f4 is on
tap
don't forget that once again where you
can play rook e8 right
if i've learned anything from the past
few months is that nepal knows his
petrol theory and his petrov usual
middle games his uh beat on rich rapport
in the candidates he's won a lot of
games uh with it in the rapid as well
okay
so c5
he knows his stuff
and by the way he has a minute and
change advantage on the clock right now
all right i'm expecting bishop e3 where
do you go after bishop e3 by the way
perhaps on d6 well if you go to
c6 i can take on a7 yeah
if you go to d6 i get bishop f4
but yeah and that's my
developing with tempo strategy that i i
love so much
bishop takes a7 bishop f6 c2 is hanging
yeah a lot of stuff is hanging right so
rook to d1 i like this inclusion look to
d1 bishop f6
perhaps and
if you do take on a7 now the a2 pawn is
hanging
because your rook is no longer wrong but
then there will be a moment where the
rook is only seven you know seventh rank
well no i think he's saying bishop takes
a7 bishop
all right and when we come yeah yeah
yeah yeah correct a2 or bishop f6
for that matter actually i think bishop
f6 i like uh i like it more
he's reaching for his bishop i suspect
he's gonna play bishop d4
or
c3 c2 c3 but yeah but now he has to be
absolutely safe right
he's going for a5 yeah yeah a5 uh a5
very very useful move
yeah reminds white that uh
rook may uh
cause of an accident oh and by the way
uh in the other game magnus is just
completely destroying yeah magnus is
destroying mamadiarov indeed in like 20
minutes or something oh he's about to
resign oh
dear
yeah maybe we could switch to this one
just to see the end yeah
i think it's important to to see the end
this one is pretty dry up to this point
it it oops excuse me that was uh
let's go to the magnus game
here i have it but i somehow i managed
to do
there's a knight on b8 that's not
getting out anytime soon there's a king
running around on h6
that's uh
that's not good news for your position
no
c7 yes i will pick up the a5 pawn as
well
wow
what a destruction it was about magnus
i've seen some pretty bad nights in my
life oh my god that's
disgusting
that's a tummy turner all right
rook to a8 followed by rook to be one
this is such a sad position ended up in
such a terrible position that is really
horrifying and even shaq is looking at
the camera saying can you believe i did
this
i mean this is terrible
who was the guy who arranged my pieces
in such a terrible way oh wait it was me
whoa did magnus overlook
rook takes c6
that's really bad i mean i mean this
part i mean everybody will play rook a8
it's still completely winning but yeah
but how are you losing alertness right
exactly
whatever just make sure that the rook is
not hanging exactly exactly
it's still completely busted for black
yeah like that is still not going
anywhere that's the problem but that's
so tragic so he captured when you're one
cheapo when the position doesn't save
you now queen takes c4
give me another pawn then rook to b7
oh maybe rook to be seven first yeah
that's what he's looking to uh and he's
done that
you're right i mean he's still winning
but wow uh
it was an oversight for sure for sure
he you know definitely is not happy with
it but you know sometimes when you have
such a dominant position you relax miro
i'd like to file a complaint
when i blunder as badly
somehow usually
it costs me you know a half a point or
more
when these guys blunder
he's still winning
that's
that's that's my protest
queen to e4 going to e4 i must say i
like queen take c4 rook b7 nobody was
stopping rook b7
uh
okay
even this is so good for white though
queen is dropping 26 bishop d5 in case
of rookie
precisely i think queen e6
with the idea of uh bishop d5 which here
you have queen e5 by the way guys jordan
is upon up
in that game against uh against snapper
wow it's not that so it's not dead yet
it's there there's something getting
but somehow
he's still surviving
bishop d5
yeah
oh that's that's pretty sad
bishop to d5 and uh
we can anticipate you take only seven
and then you go c7 yeah yeah
and there's just a piece and a couple of
pawns after that
yeah i mean magnus is starting to pick
up the pace guys truly he uh he was not
happy about his uh two
initial losses yeah this is okay
your victory in a row right
yeah jordan needs to win in order to
maintain the lead that means right
exactly and wesley needs to win in order
to keep up with carlson
whoa whoa okay what's going on
there's a check in the position in queen
e6 you're a couple of pawns up but
you know
wait a minute you could be losing this
queen f2 queenie e6 and how do you stop
rookie two yeah do you play like d
five d five d five yeah
d5 you can take on d4 with the pawn
right you probably should
right now right now and yeah and then is
white sometimes like rook c4 maybe maybe
i'll be on time return turning but it's
not guaranteed right that's right and he
has done it yeah ruxin and roxy for just
in time wait queen e6 is it nice
it's like d3 yeah and then rookie two
yeah yeah
and then i take on e2 and then i put the
queen on e1 so how do you see that e6
i think that's okay for white
uh h that's why he played the h5 oh
there was a background matrix what am i
thinking geez hi
i i guess it was on h6 no that pawn was
on h6 oh good because i was on h6 yeah
but
queen e6
what am i doing after queen e6
g6 queen e6 rook c2
but then he trains
queen e1 that's what christian explained
us
i hide and then i push my pawns and i
use them as decoy
fair
rook c c three well we put the rook on
d2
and i'm assuming dvd happens
by the way not so easy to
advance these guys
this very very active rook
excellent queen to
king of two okay so he's running with
the king
it's very tricky
absolutely now for instance there is
queen a5 move right and that's what he
he does eventually between a5 and a5 so
that they feel i mean you're forced to
take
apparently by the way maxine
mvl has won his game against topalov who
is black yeah wesley still play what you
were saying lots of victories with the
black pieces in this blitz 20 under 20
seconds for
van forest
his position is to figure out right now
how
he stops the c pawn if he stops the cpu
a4 a4 he says i don't care
it's not going anywhere well the problem
is that queen
how about that
that's a problem
that's a problem yeah but queen d1 and
then okay you do have so you give a
check press
one check right and then the moment
now you go back to c4 right but no queen
d2 resignation yeah queen d2 check is
queen d2 checking
let's jump to wesley is wesley winning
this one
he is up against
lanier no wesley lost
what
time that that's uh
that was alireza no no no no no no we
made a mistake there we're still on the
game between wesley wesley as the queen
versus rook and bishop
chances for fortress
but
definitely that wesley is
for choice absolutely his king can
where can his king go even if this gets
his king all the way to b7 which is
nice
i mean he's trying to
but i think this is just a fortress
right yeah it looks like
it looks like i'm not so sure you will
try to get the king somewhere on
e8 and then and then what because rook
to f8 is coming all the time
whoa
that's okay so he went back to d4 and
then exchanged his b pawn for
[Music]
the rook has two squares
from which is protected f8 and f6 i
don't think you can make any progress
based on that right even if i get in g4
and g5
yeah but the but then
you have the fortress with rook along
the sixth floor yeah yes i think you're
right i think this is just a clear
fortress
is
time factor
yeah
of course but
it's not like
dominguez is really long time king of
four but where's the king going i don't
quite get it
you just have to be careful you don't
end up putting your king in some
bishop d2 checkmate
pattern right
okay so the king went all the way from
g2 to b5 and all the way back
that was quite big
and then finally he goes with g4
but yeah but now we are waiting on the i
mean
okay he goes fade even for that
matter f6 and d6 squares yeah f6 and d6
is already like an easy fortress you're
absolutely right yes sir
yeah and then
it's actually known to be a fortress
like if you remove all the queen side
the pawns and the bishop if rook does
not lose against uh the queen and not
only was this set up
the rook you could have uh three extra
pawns pawns on h4 h3h2 oh yeah and it's
still a draw jan timmon taught me that
one and i was like he he's a problemist
yanus yeah you really have to have a
specific set of mind to even check such
positions
what happens if i add you're right
yeah well once
does he really see some sort of a plan
because black's not doing all that much
right no
and the draw moves no i like how wesley
just like makes the move and then with
the other hand shakes yeah exactly
he's a lefty and his
right hand
wow
jordan van forest uh
when we left it we actually thought he
was a little bit better then we got news
that he was upon up
um how did he actually end up
losing this position because we left it
it was
kind of better for him before a tree be
tree um
still i think i prefer white exactly at
this point ooh g3 i'm not a big fan
rook's queen c1 maybe
was necessary now here already
something has gone wrong because we were
looking at
ideas of
queen e6 and we were thinking
gosh
is he is white supposed to lose this
no
perhaps no can can't be that bad can it
but in a blitz game it's so difficult
right i mean that pawn is well he could
play king he won perhaps king you won
that's probably what you should have
done but queen takes d3 next we should
be okay
i think uh this is where it goes wrong
oh this is already yeah it's over yeah
wow a
huge win actually
and
once again it kind of
changes the tournament standings uh a
great deal
and guess who floated to the top finally
finally it's magnus carson leading the
tournament alone and look at his result
in the blitz alongside john nepo so
equals with five points out of seven
right here he's taken him 16 uh 16
rounds
16 rounds to right the ship but he's
finally there
and what else caught your attention
christian well let's take a look at what
happened in this game between firuja and
saric because actually the croatian
superstar won his game with the black
pieces and kicked for russia out of
contention right now e4 c5 knight to f3
took a very early on um aggressive
stance as black but we know saric is a
fighter and furuja was not going to back
out
of that h3 and this is the critical
moment in my eyes after d5 knight to a7
e5 knight to d7 bishop takes d7 queen
takes d7 and at this point firuja lost a
tempo what he should have done was keep
the bishop on b7 closed with the move a
b4 you were this was an imperial uh
decision for him knight to f1 was played
the problem is after d4 and the opening
of the bishop on b7 this is really bad
news this bishop is going to be a
monster for the remaining of the game
and let's take a look after c4 f5 i
really like this move once again by
saric opening up the files and the
diagonals towards the white king this
bishop is going to come on d6 at the
same time you're giving up some squares
sure this knight is going to come to e5
so there are trade-offs like with
everything in life bishop take c7 knight
to g3 rook to f4 queen to h5 rook to e2
this was the critical mistake forgetting
about the fact that the queen doesn't
have any way back home and rook to h4
came on the board trapping the queen and
pretty much after this is all she wrote
this is resignation at this point what a
beautiful and important victory for ivan
starridge the croatian superstar and
speaking of croatia we do have our
friends in zagreb anastasia and
alejandro what did you guys have your
eyes on
thank you christian good to be back in
the program and we did keep our eye on
two of the games that you guys didn't
have a chance to cover of course
exciting news that the world champion
takes the first place again but let's
take a look at some of the games a
little bit on the lower boards we have
this one between vaseline topalov and
we know he's not in the best shape but
maxine has also not been performing as
well as we would expect from the world
blitz champion yes actually he plays
really interesting chess but so far not
so good i mean let's say it didn't bring
him success but in this particular game
he decided probably to play just
something simple you know he just took
this bishop and went for the ending
quest to bishops
against knight and bishop and just want
he wants to say okay let's just play it
and see how it happens so what will
happen and then in the end he just put
pressure on the queen side i'm just
making logical moves um
exchange couple of pawns and it turned
out that actually pieces of white are
not placed so well and he just
simply
were moving basically also pawns on the
king side and we came to this very
important moment where i really don't
want to be on the place or whistling to
power play and i mean defending this
ending right yes so actually it's a very
difficult moment for him because uh he
really needs to keep his calm and just
put the pieces there maybe rook has
three something like this then rook d3
maybe go back and just keep the position
uh which is not that easy because
actually he cannot move other pieces
especially that knight right this knight
on d2 is blocking all the pieces and
when he puts this rook on d1
the lack of coordination no space two
bishops for like a really unpleasant
position but still maybe he could have
hold it better so after rook d1 i mean
just uh black keep
growing his um advantage and at the end
of the day he just took more material
and won eventually the game so it's a
very important victory for maxime who
was suffering so far i think it will it
may change a little bit track of his
tournament yeah the big result for the
standings is that wesley so wasn't able
to break through you guys saw the
fortress that end of the game between
the queen against the rook and bishop
but let's take a look at how we got
there because it was a very long game
and it was a very long game for lanier
without a queen all the way from this
position after a kind of weird opening
this d4 break happens and you can see
the tension in the center these pawns
touching each other in the center means
that something will open up and black
hasn't developed a lot of pieces
consider the bishop on ca the rook on a8
also the fact that you have this
weakened diagonal or to the king on g8
so it is possible to play a move like e4
close things up he must have been afraid
of a tactic but instead he saw this
resource just taking up a pawn and he
must have expected wesley to immediately
recapture on d4 especially if white
recaptures with the queen black has
absolutely no trouble takes stakes takes
yes a little bit of pressure but let's
be honest metric upon symmetrical
material should be a draw nothing
special at all but instead wesley hits
him with this move rook e1 it was an
awesome move it puts pressure over
black's position doesn't let him develop
freely if bishop e6 rook takes queen
takes bishop c4 just wins
so instead lanier plays a move bishop d7
czech king h8 and after a4 it looks like
wesley is totally in control the move
bishop a3 is coming that's cure on the
queen on d6 bishop on e7 looks fatal but
a great understanding here in my opinion
by linear dominguez the engines hate his
move hate the move rook 88 because they
think that just blunders what i
explained bishop a3 but he was very
clever after bishop a3 he instantly took
on a3 took back bishop takes queen takes
d4 b6 and actually the engines regress
their evaluation a little bit after
looking at the queen sacrifice because
they realized wait a second it's not so
easy it's not easy at all and it wasn't
easy for wesley who despite having two
minutes and 30 seconds at this position
against 37 seconds of lanier was unable
to convert the queen against the rook
and bishop so trailing still wesley so
he's going to have to pick up more
points throughout the day because well
you know when magnus gets that lead it's
tough to catch him absolutely so we'll
see what will happen next yeah we still
have two games of blitz here in zagreb
back to the studio
good to have you back with us anastasia
and
alejandro we're just having a little
technical problems nice that
that worked out we
didn't catch all of anastasia's analysis
there but i just wanted to throw a
curveball at our audience and
highlight a certain moment that occurred
earlier in the event between shaq
and farrugia this game ended in a draw
but it's almost a study-like position
and i will challenge our audience and
say white to move and win
well shaq did not
find the winning move but it's a very
pretty one when you consider the
position after the move h6 what you want
to do is play g6 and after captures
h7 and coronate
uh the h-pawn and there's nothing that
black can do the knight on f5 is like a
it's almost study-like it was very nice
a missed opportunity that was much
earlier but i tell you my horse ali raza
kind of falling off the pace and magnus
really picking up the pace but also i
think it's really pretty this move h6
because the king is on c3 that means the
bishop doesn't have a way to get on the
long diagonal that's right in time if
the king was on c2 then you can go
bishop before bishop c3 and be fine
right the problem is the king on c3
coupled with the fact that the knight is
like a tarantula controlling absolutely
every single square the bishop can go to
is just allows this h6 g6 in time very
beautiful yeah
it's it struck me uh the same and uh
once more our current standing yeah
after all of these uh rounds uh it it
seems like uh magnus carlsen is
beginning to put his signature
on this event where do we stand yeah
let's take a look because well magnus i
get it but he wasn't my pick anyway so
let me see let me see how jan is doing
yeah well not so bad we had two points
behind magnus so second place for wesley
saw 15 and a half well they're tied for
the second exactly wesley saw jordan one
forest and jan was climbing up in front
of your boyfriend that's awesome i'm
sorry yes you're making a good point but
two points behind magnus who is
beginning to soar
uh with five from seven two rounds
remaining in uh this day of blitz again
nine rounds tomorrow you're right
perugia a player i really
thought would excel in blitz who
wouldn't two and a half
and our upcoming games for round eight
mirror yeah so set the table dominguez
mvl against wesley so well that's an
important one yep and nepal faces the
follow-up with white managiarov will
have white against one for rest and we
will be
marquee yeah absolutely that's
absolutely ferrugiacarte
carson so this time this is the match
that magnus wanted to happen as the
world championship match okay you don't
get the match but at least you have to
play in blitz yeah in blitz and again uh
wesley so just on the outside
with a shared second in jordan van poros
of shaq
also will be our backup games but
perugia
magnus
sounds exciting christian no absolutely
and i was just trying to figure out when
did things go wrong for a van forest in
that game right because he was upon up
yes at this point and i was like okay
he's uh pulling some magic right um
pulling a rabbit out of his hat and
maybe even winning this game against
nebo and taking soul lead well that
didn't happen because of this last move
g3 yeah which allowed the move a d4 i
think this is what he missed the idea
being that after you take on d4 i'm not
forced to take back on d4 of course you
will just simply pick up the pawn on d4
but i can exchange a pair of rooks first
take advantage of the fact that you
weakened the long diagonal so if you do
go for example
king to g2 i'll have some queen d5
checks and this is just simply going to
be game over right you cannot do that
you have to go to h2 but only after you
exchange and this is exactly what we got
and after c takes d4 despite the fact
that you're a pawn up and you have two
connected passers this is the patters
the passer that matters especially
because of the fact that i can couple it
with the newly created weakness on the
second rank very beautiful play by nepo
just simply taking advantage of every
single mistake that van4 has made along
the way very beautiful game and that
actually takes nepo where do we stand in
terms of uh standings how how far is
nepo
from the two years two points off the
page that's not bad well
two points is two points
and magnus is the guy you're trying to
catch we have two games remaining nine
tomorrow so 11 and all yeah there's
plenty of time to catch him but uh
people are gonna have to put together
strings of victories look guys i'm not
complaining i'm trying to remember who
picked magnus to win the event
nobody remembers strangers
could this be
strange that nobody remembers that and
let me bring up our marquee match-up
game so that will be ali brezza ferruga
with magnus yes
yes absolutely
seated down yeah i have it in mind in
the world blitz championships they have
played a few games that
were actually dramatic
uh
also not because of everything that
happened on the board but there were
some issues with things that were going
around the clocks and
uh
they they have a history in blitz yeah
these two
they have a history and alibraza
unfortunately for him right now
he feels a little bit on tilt
today yes he's been losing a lot of
games he's just not been himself today
yeah he's not in his
proper
mode magnus on the other hand yeah what
was that his third or fourth victory in
a row i mean he's definitely on a roll
well no draws i don't know he started
with two wins
but then he started two lost
wow uh he's put up a brace yeah speaking
of ali reza don't you think he is a you
know like a youngest participant and
clearly
the next generation of the magnus right
you think he feels a bit uncomfortable
playing blitz over the board
no
i didn't see a handshake by the way
maybe we came a little late and i don't
think we see a lot of handshakes
actually in blitz they just start the
clock and they they get going
really i think so i uh
yeah i'm trying to remember whether we
we've seen as many handshakes obviously
in rapid and classical you see a lot of
them uh an invitation to
uh
the gambits uh the bodine gambit the
moscow variation nope just bishop e7
and we have a traditional queen's gambit
declined
uh
set up so uh
magnus was
if he was bluffing
these uh gambit positions uh ferusha
called his bluff and he said no no no
i'm not gonna play yeah
the bad winnick
keeps playing his king's gambit
look when you're not getting anything
against
the berlin
[Laughter]
why not
oh my goodness rook d1
b7 b6
and a very normal bishop to b7 am i c6
it used to be the long castle move
instead of d1 yeah and
i have seen
just about everything under the sun
crazily enough including g4
uh in those positions as well
but okay one of the things that's
i find intriguing is magnus is not
including
h7h6 right and bishop h4 right
because this last move rook d1 now stops
castles i think that's precisely the
reason why he's not including h6 and
bishop h4 because you have ideas of g4
as white bingo absolutely and now
once we see castles h6
with
h6 on q that's interesting and c5 or
rook c8 c5 but c5 is the traditional way
of
fighting back in the center
absolutely and that looks great right
nepal now much worse against apollo just
giving you a quick update
by the way uh just mentioning the
etiquette there
uh magnus played the move rook c8
and somehow when he withdrew his hand
the rook tilted over he set the rook
back up on his own time
and then pressed the clock
i always appreciate proper play
and that was quite proper of the world
champion
rooksy a queen queen b1 and now either
we take on c4 or play c5 immediately
mero um i'd be playing c5 and let's go
yeah i mean i'm not sure if c5 is that
comfortable with this opposition of
white's rook on d1 and black's queen on
d8 that's yeah and i want to trade and
put my queen on e7
and he is taking the time
c5 us and perhaps now if i take consider
maybe you take with the rook can this be
yeah
right right
bishop f3 could be a thing too ah sorry
i learned cop shown f3 intermediate and
then take on c5 with the rook with the
10 point then queen a8 could it be that
magnus is already kind of slightly
taking over the initiative maybe maybe
he's not better yet he's taking over on
time as well queen b1 was not in my
opinion
the
sharpest maybe you should just play
bishop e2 and
be satisfied well here we go bishop f3
or rook c5
so now it's a question yeah rook c5
keeps kind of the same pieces on the
board but after bishop e2 at least you
cannot really double the pawns that's
right you cannot but you can set up this
very annoying
battery
i mean i still want to capture on f3 for
whatever reason i think you have to take
the queen off the d file and put it on
the c file connected with knight on d7
right but then you can take on d7 never
mind no no you can't do this that's not
a that's not a move
yeah wait so what do you do now uh
f3 go knight d5 can i do this
knight e5 d5
bishop takes f3 gf3 and knight f6 to d5
right yeah that makes a lot of sense
again inviting the
trade of bishops on e7
that'd be also a nice way of defending
the uh but perhaps move bishop to b5 but
saves ali reza from well having to
defend the worst position well
what if i just play the move a6
you have to play bishop f6 if you're
looking for an imbalance right sure
so then what do you do yeah i take on b5
then i take only seven you take back
and you're claiming that your position
is
well or okay i
by the way a long thing here for a blitz
game by magnus right one minute and 30
seconds on this one and he played asics
we were just you're a player
no we were just looking at it but also
bishop f3
knight d5 i like that resolution way of
resolving
the difficulties as well i think magnus
had
difficulty between two attractive
options
he didn't apply the sarah juan field
theory
sarah juan field theory is whenever
you're confronted
with two desirable
choices options
you must expand your capacity to accept
both
[Laughter]
a knight e5 whoa
guys it just got spicy
out of nowhere out of nowhere magnus
taken aback
by this move wait a minute so what do
you do now do you take on that you
probably saw queen somehow i don't think
you can take bishop f6 knight d7 and g5
rook g5 is there but f3 then and
it's still this knight
or even knight e4 after rook g5 might be
right
okay things are definitely heated up in
this one okay this is uh once again
taking long thing and he was up a minute
and 30 seconds now he's down 10 seconds
on the clock that move knight e5 really
rocked the world champion knight takes
f6 rook takes d8 rook takes d8 is
not
the most attractive queen sacrifice
we've ever made
bishop bishop yeah
this got to be wrong for somehow seizing
the
defensive spot
that's the question
okay how do we refute this one mirror
and we got to put on our thinking caps i
feel like bishop take c7 has to be
played right yeah you probably oh wait
i'm thinking 97
bishop back to d4 ah maybe you want to
keep the dark square bishop i'm not sure
he's great
i guess like trade everything go okay he
keeps the knights as well i thought
knight d7 83 you know and just tried to
play it
the the position of these two pieces
bishop on c8 and 97 i don't
want to trade off on d7 rook g5
telegraphing that yeah if you've got any
weaknesses in the position it's that
this big thing on g1
but wait a minute there's no bishop four
seven so what is the rook doing on g5
let's go h4 why not what
h4
why not lifting your kimono doesn't i'm
i'm lifting the kimono but
i about knight e i'm really hunting that
rook i like knight d4 as well 94
94 i go rook d5 and then knight f4 and
then knight f4 and we exchange the rooks
i i feel like the black rook on g5 is
just the target in the position a3
that's the move i would have never
that's that's relaxed if i ever seen a
relaxed move chill chill that's a real
that's a good one a
three okay yeah that wasn't the first
one on my radar either i have to go
bishop b7 has to come
why else did we play rook g5 no says
magnus knight to c5 wow
hard to guess these moves
knight to c5
second debate f4 yes nobody's interested
in b5 bishop b7 and now f3 is blocking
the bishop
makes a lot of sense okay
knight to a4 so crafty
maybe in order to
take away the pressure from the b fight
also once you play the move f3 queen to
c5 is coming attacking that pawn on e3
you're starting to see a lot of
weaknesses in white's position
through
that and the knight on f4 you've avoided
this trade of the knights but the knight
on f4 what is he doing right now yeah i
was wondering if i can use the uh d4
square maybe take and play rook to d4
of course i have to be careful about
eating five might be a problem yeah
very much so but i mean i've got the
open d file i i should be able to use it
continuing to avoid the trade of the
knights
that are stating that yeah your dice
your knight on a4 is not doing all that
much to see it improving the last piece
okay knight to d4 unfortunately doesn't
work because of e5
true that
e4 ek
[Music]
very happy bishop but b4 now can we play
b4
yes he does we'll take with the queen in
case white captures and bishop a6 will
be the diagonal right the a6 f1 diagonal
for the bishop absolutely that was the
thing that uh farugia really
wanted to do was kill the bishop
and the move b4 does open up that that
ooh and how do we feel about queen to c5
now king has to move or knight d3 sorry
queen to c5923
yes that's a good one and by the way we
have a big result chakri armamenterov
drew his game against holding on foreign
[Laughter]
queen c4 i thought the knight was gonna
look at this wait a minute he's got rook
d7 but what about bishop a6 that's okay
you can go to d7
does that help you that much bishop to
a6 point bishop a6 and
there could be dangers on the diagonal
c6 bishop cc magnus's decision but this
doesn't happen there's d7
a rook to
one or c12
queen d2 black i don't like this one
once again if you take on a3 the bishop
the knight on a4 i'm a little bit
worried about e5 guys oh yeah by the way
that's a
known as the ford right
he takes on a three rook takes a look at
the door b2 is that his right takes big
questions
attacking the queen attacking the rook
what is he counting
the c8 with a check he's saying that his
extra piece doesn't matter my a pawn is
stronger now the a pawn is very strong
knights are tied to one another i'm not
sure about that decision guys bishop b5
rook to e1 you're simply defending
he's coming to h5 with something
no this has to be winning queen c5 check
and just use the d6 e5 queen d2 okay so
he proves you just have to trade the
queens but keep the pawns connected
but but the bishop is coming to c4
a2 and at least you go into that end
game
and try to say that you're going to have
a fortress on the dark squares
fortress will you though king goes to
work might be full
no but why wouldn't you go with the king
first
well bishop attacked the knight on a2
bishop d5 you lose another pawn this is
over yes you do yeah i mean you're gonna
take it back but after king d4 that
that's like
a score that's a very magnusi player at
the very end you know i
eve
we'll go to
any games remaining yes there is uh the
mvl versus wesley okay
wesley is a pawn up
two knights versus bishop and knight and
an extra pawn for wesley
but you know it's very strange
the body postures of the players going
into the game it just felt like
farouza was tired can i say it like that
he's until no fear is just simply on
tilt yeah he's not happy with his
performance right now how do you feel
about wesley's chances to win this one
excellent
really he's a pawn up
better than anybody else
yes exactly captain obvious uh
not very good anymore this move knight
to d8
oh
i haven't seen this one in a while okay
no neither five check
knight five check that did not change
much
all righty and we still have one game
right uh i think that's it that's it
yeah dominguez won against saric nepo
won against apollo with the kings gambit
wow and what else mummy diaz made the
draw against one foreign
so um
lanier even though he had a very poor
rapid result is actually
very impressive
blitz result
uh how how many is that i think he was a
half a point behind magnus right but
magnus keeps winning
he keeps
i mean that's the problem
and magnus wins and maintains his lead
how did
not only that he maintains his lead but
i think that
for his draw he extends his league yeah
both
forest and wesley made the draw right
that's one clear point
wow
that's the thing about magnus guys once
he starts winning it's very difficult to
stop him yes he gets on his role really
stringing those victories together
nicely
and uh let's take a look at what
happened actually in this game of nepal
who is surging in the rankings he came
into the blitz section quite a lot
behind now not so much now let's take a
look he
opened with the king's gambit again we
don't see this at the top level almost
at all there's a reason for that usually
you get worse positions and this is
exactly what happened in this game as
well topalov
didn't know how to play the position and
he actually got a slightly better
position but after knight to g3 rook to
h2 queen to e7 knight to d to knight
takes b3 knight to h5 and now knight to
c4 this was the moment at which topalov
had to understand that it is time to
keep the knights on the board because e5
is coming and e5 is going to be coupled
with the idea of getting the knight to
d6 so what he was supposed to do was to
play the move knight to f6 and after e5
take on e5 take on e5 rook to d8 start
with the move rook to d8 now knight to
d6 i'm just simply going to give you the
exchange and this is just going to lead
into a better end game despite the fact
that you are an exchange up your pieces
are extremely awkward i'm going to go
castle gather kanye and uh your king is
in fact very unsafe in the position
he did not do that he played the move g6
and unfortunately for him after knight
takes h5 g takes a shrive if you do take
with the bishop bishop to f4 and the
bishop is quite awkward and you still
have a lot of difficulties to stabilize
the position
related to the dark squares in the
center especially this pawn on d6 is
fragile in the position if you defend it
with rook to d8 first of all your pawn
on a7 is hanging but i will also be able
to open you up after the move e5 so
quite problematic position for you right
now bishop to f4 and unfortunately after
this move beautiful move knight to b6
taking advantage of the fact that you
cannot take the rookies hanging on a8
after rook to a7 it is all about the
white position right now he's just
breaking through i'm completely safe on
this side there's no more g5 the bishop
f4 is going to hold together white's
position and he went on to win a very
nice game and let's take a look at what
happened in mahmediro versus van forest
this was the game in which you mentioned
mira that um
van forest was held to a draw with the
black pieces by mamedyarov and that is
exactly what happened in fact because he
did get a better position out of this
groomfeld let's take a look
it was this end game that i thought he's
slightly better at some point i will
just be able to go uh with the move e5
which was not played if you do go uh d5
then i go c4 block this pawn on c3 i'm
going to open up the bishop with the
move e4 and you're going to have some
difficulties stabilizing the position as
white a lot of weaknesses in your
position and this d-pawn it looks like
an asset at this point but it can easily
turn into a liability if i managed to
corral it and be able to attack it uh
this was the critical move c takes d4
was played and after this a lot of
exchanges have happened not a lot of
imbalances in the position and the game
ended in a draw and uh how about our
friends anastasia and alejandro in
zagreb what do you guys have
thank you christian of course we had two
other interesting games especially
important for the standings to follow
wesley so as mvl was playing with the
white pieces against him anastasia you
had your eyes on this one yeah they just
finished the game i was even checking
how they were playing in the hall you
know everybody was watching and
uploading right after it finished so i
would like just to show the moment when
it was deep in the ending because before
that the fight was pretty tense but
level i mean all the time they were
keeping the balance at this moment uh
wesley so decided to go volume he played
g4 and actually white had an interesting
option not to take on g4 immediately but
maybe try to play e5 and if takes on the
street queen takes f3 and if black moves
his knight in the center then like queen
g4 you know trying to take advantage of
this king who is a little bit more open
at this moment so but um at this moment
uh maxim took on g4 and here the fights
has started a little bit i mean because
the position became a little bit more
complicated probably e5 was a mistake
here so he was too optimistic and him
because wesley so found this question he
must have missed queen b
i think so so let's see what to do now
after queen of b7 white has no move so
he had to exchange the queens and you
can see what happened after i mean
down and believe it or not but maxine
managed to somehow uh hold this uh
ending yeah the unbelievable part is not
easy for black west he kept trying kept
trying but despite being up a pawn
those knights on c4 and b5 and the
advanced position of the floor on e5 is
hard to break through absolutely yes so
they played of course they played until
the end and wesley is a fighter he
always tries to use every chance he has
and um eventually the game finished in
the draw i like that at the very end
they had only the knight and the king
left on the board yes everybody was
uploading at this moment okay that was a
nice game but we you kept an eye on your
eyes on the other game right yeah
croatian star ivan saric was against
lanier dominguez and guys this was a
game of emotions let me take you through
what happened in this one a patch of
that well christian and i are well
acquainted with this was the world
championship preparation that fabiano
carolina used against magnus carlsen in
2018 and
sarge came up with this move d6 said
lanier into a deep thought remember
lanier was part of that team with us in
2018 so he knows this variation very
well he thought for a while considering
it was a blitz game and decided to play
the imprecise move bishop f8 actually he
should have taken on d3 call the bluff a
little bit they take c7 check on c2 take
on c2 queen takes e7 and things are
about equal the computer prefers uh
black a little bit because this bishop
on c8 could become powerful but let's
not worry about that let's see what
happened in the game instead after
bishop f8 uh
some adventures happened and eventually
we got to this position in which yvonne
sacrifices this knight on g5 but you
just cannot touch it yes you open the h
file and you die so
he had to dominguez was then allowed
this bishop takes f6 destroying his pawn
structure in the king side and it looks
like it's really bad for black and while
i was watching this game it looked
horrible for black but i just
surprisingly think it's okay for the
black side the bishop is just very
powerful kind of crazy to believe so
right really i cannot believe it even
now that you see the position that you
tell me this and what happens is that
for a human you can analyze this and
think you're much better and i think
both players thought white is better in
this position and played it accordingly
and white eventually did start taking
over queen f4 queen e4 queen takes f6
and the compensation for the pawn was
insufficient and we got to this position
where it is clear yvonne is much better
and despite the fact that this is not a
big game for the standings the croatians
were all focused on this game they saw
sarge winning and they were so
interested of course all the reservoirs
are playing against magnus carlsen it's
like the room was split half of them
were on the right side looking at magnus
half of them were on the left side
looking at the sirechi's game and
everybody was so excited and cyrus
continued played very powerfully up
until this point look at how well he's
playing he's placing his rook on f2
attacking the black king going for the
hunt and he had the point in the back in
this position he has several options the
move rogue g2 is winning rook takes f7
is for example winning queens takes
queen e5 a simple distraction tactic
down here the move rook g2 just straight
up finishes the game rook g7 is coming
mate is unavoidable but in time pressure
the croatian superstar couldn't hold his
nerves together started playing
passively and look what happened the
table stirred completely the king on h6
somehow is still getting made it but it
didn't get made it look at how it
survives queen g4 not actually with the
threat and lanier started with his
advances a5 threatening b4 out of where
out of where does black at this counter
play queen f4 b4 takes takes takes and
this was the losing move saric must have
missed this move queen a7 or rookie one
he must have forgotten something yeah c3
maybe he counted only i don't know maybe
c3 maybe c3
yeah perhaps e3 and in this position he
must have forgotten about this move
queen a4 and unfortunately for him his
king is just getting hunted down with
checks no chance for him rookie five
check and at this point when rookie five
came on the board sarah just grabbed his
head in disbelief you could see the
audience like gasping it was over at
this point he had to resign a couple of
moves later because he's just simply
getting mated and i saw yvonne outside
of the studio he was just holding his
head like this walking up and down he
just couldn't believe that he threw away
such a great opportunity against
dominguez and it seems to be the story
of his tournament yes actually i heard
him saying just before the game
that actually he can lose every position
probably he said this and this is what
he has done yeah and
consider how many
games in the rapid that he was just
winning against mohammad yara for
example that completely won end game and
sarge should have so many more points
but he's just not getting them in this
event that's a pity and i hope that he
will you know now put his tracks
together and we'll try to win couple of
games absolutely one round only one
round only one round of blitz left here
in zagreb it's been a long day and we
won more games of chess but we'll have
one more today a bunch more tomorrow
let's go to a short commercial break
before the last
round of today's splits
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our last
round of blitz this is round nine miro
do the honors please uh okay so we have
our leader magnus carlsen paired against
ivan saric we have young guns playing
against each other one for rest and
fierruja toppalov will have the white
pieces against mohammed yarov dominguez
against washiela grave by the way lean
gear is performing very well very well
indeed and the game the key match up is
of course wesley saw against young nepal
mission okay that will be our marquee
matchup we'll keep the
gordon van poros ferugia games as well
as magnus in reserve and will stay with
wesley
and nepo now
napo is a consistent use of the kings
gambit it's very funny i was looking at
checking on our computer the game and it
went e4 e5 f4 question mark by the
computers
that was a that was rather a funny
moment for
i didn't realize it had gotten that bad
yeah that's what i don't like about the
modern engines yeah and
not the engines themselves but like the
way people use it over extensive sort of
right because come on it's blitz it's
fun to play queen's gum a king's gun
video and let's do it and we have a
nimzo on the board with and the thing is
nepal was not in contention
going into the blitz section
really behind right points
so he was just trying to have some fun
and he is he achieved it and then this
nimzo with uh queen c2
castles my goodness has the theory
developed you just have to know your
stuff inside and out
and by the way a big situation right now
magnus has returned as number one in the
live ratings when it comes to blitz
surpassing hikaru nakamura yeah hikaru
says wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute i want i want to get in coaching
let me throw some paddies yeah but when
when you were talking about this live
rating i was so surprised that hikaru
was on 2850 and magnusson 28 35 so 15
point behind and he was only fours yes
that means
somebody's tiny gap yeah it's it's fabio
you'd be surprised and aronian who are
there number two and three he had a very
good uh world of blitz championship as
well as at the grand chester in poland
he did really well in that one fabiano
that is exactly he certainly did uh
poland by the way duda was
absolutely amazing and look at these
players play the most
fearsome looking position
and they're blessing it and they're
blitzing because yeah they're blessing
because they are still in the database
if you check the database
it's a lot of games and most of them if
not all of them finish drawing and in a
draw yeah wow
and look at that they just played it
right through
but you know what that means
that means magnus might have another
opportunity to extend his lead
because he's playing sarge with the
white pieces right
exactly no
what
i mean even though i can see from my
database that we're still in um
and a lot of draws of course
what is this what's going on yeah what
has just helped me out here uh
miro we just had
rook
rook to see it yeah is is h7 poison
king g7 i'm guessing i'm using the h
file that's why i'm saying is it poison
i think it was that was my weight
this is difficult now i could still
theory yeah i could possibly take on c3
with the rook which it does seem like
has to be played not with the rook but
actually with the bishop
really if you take with the rook i think
queen to e4 and you might be in some
some trouble and so after bishop seven
you take a one white takes c8 you take a
game
no actually the move right now is queen
to d1
is what he plays which was played and
just i guess these guys are they know
they know their stuff
they sure do know their stuff
rook c4 yeah you you can take on f5 you
can also take on d4 but you can also
play rook to c4 which is the best movie
in the position wow and yeah that's move
21 we are talking about in a database
you still have a game between m we hal
and anish geary
basics
what was the previous move
rook takes d4 rook takes c4 and then it
draws inevitably e6 rook to e1
and a draw yes
actually no nvl won that game
wow yes he did
i'm not sure how we're not going to go
into details in that on that one but he
won that game
wow
okay this seems to be this might be
quiet i mean if you ask me
after what we're discussing and watching
i tell you fischer random chest never
never seems so good and we do have a
fish of random uh coming up a little
later this summer
uh i think that's actually going to be
louis november right
is it
no i thought it was after the sinkville
club oh that one i thought you were
talking about the world championship in
fisher random ah well that that but yes
the 9lx chestnine lx is going to come in
september yes yes
that was the one i had in mind in fact
the world championship official random
kind of
disappeared it had been it's coming back
this year it is it is coming back this
year wonderful there is the reigning
champion is wesley saw who actually took
down magnus carlsen i was there i
witnessed it and it was a it was a
command performance i must say by wesley
absolutely no uh
that was a very fun match to watch and
wesley what is he looking at i i know
that there's screens above him he just
seems bored both players to be honest
seemed pretty bored guys i i don't think
there's going to be anything so we have
always won his game very fast against
muhammad yara sir
one of the games stopped at the screen
and they were like who you can't really
help but check the results right right
uh well i guess i'm sorry guys i think
we have to make an executive decision
let's go to magnus yeah bishops of
opposite colors
if you don't mind magnus is taking over
i mean let's go to magnus this is just
he's really putting in the works
okay a very exciting
slav-like defense uh knight e5 bishop f4
look at him go with d5
i don't think queen c7 saric can be very
happy with the current position right
now queen c7 wait to see that one but ap
five
right
there first well i wasn't going to
recapture queen to c7 i can take on b5
right
quincy it's still played three five yeah
knight to d7 knight to d7 that's what i
wanted to avoid actually
well i'm gonna sacrifice an exchange
yeah probably you do
exactly how am i supposed to sacrifice
the exchange not easy
maybe bishop takes a knight d3
provided i can
win this pawn on c6 one day
uh
by the way
it seems that my d7 wasn't the strongest
right
knight d3 knight d5 that is the three
knight d5 okay
he apparently
missed knight d5 because that's how it's
really critical
now it's really really critical now you
have to go back to d8 right
is there any other way to defend against
knight takes e7
to h8 but i'm not happy
it just doesn't look very uh very good i
think queen d8 has to be played but if
you have to go queen d8 and just give me
the exchange for free
it's not good news
nope it's not good news at all not only
that
is coming after that as well
in fact perhaps after knight f8 you have
to take on c6 first
right
and just say the knight's trapped so
i make sure to get that c pawn off the
board
do i have any other
perhaps better alternatives than knight
xf8
maybe not because now
with the knight on d3 i'm probably ready
to take on d7 and then b2 is hanging yes
absolutely
taking and but it does feel like black
gets some sort of initiative after
bishop the ac6 anything what about
a b
bishop i will take on d7 and i take on
d7
now is the question what do i do e6
yeah e6 is a good move just chasing me
away from d5 yeah as trying to
yeah i know
take advantage of the moment but i think
he's going for that doesn't feel right
like the rook from f8 is not even moving
yeah i mean you want to kind of
expose black and he's done a b okay
bishop takes ponte is it e6 let's see if
e6 is going to be found by yeah e6 and
i tell you what the black will be better
in this position according to the engine
okay maybe no matter
when d7 ba6 and now it's once again in
magnus's hands yeah
and by the way that was a big
opportunity for
each
other yeah knight b6 is that fret yeah
but after okay seven one of the moves
i'm looking at is e5 you know block the
block the bishop
which is hitting b2
you know this knight on d3 is the one
good news
that black has in the position but
you're right e5
magnus spotted the same
idea that's a nice move and how about e6
now
e6 now can i
e6
we are going
maybe but then i can go knight takes f4
so knight b6 screen c7 knight c4 knight
four
yeah and then i have to move my queen
and away we go um
queen to e6 maybe can we take it
wait a minute i really like this move b4
now
b4 i want to connect my pawns and you
cannot take on b3 the knight is hanging
yeah that's
right yeah
but when you look at you know before
is a good move yeah before and then you
keep some ideas of even sacrificing an
exchange on d3 and then running with the
pawns quickly happily
speaking of which sacrificing the
exchange on d3 on the last move also
had some
really
something good to say about it
tonight
played with two seconds on the clock
queen takes we just forgot events
outreach has four seconds left
queen takes c4 looks like a queen c3
to jordan then forest and uh ali riza
farouzia we are in round nine
of nine rounds of blitz today we'll have
nine rounds of blitz tomorrow and what
do we have we have extra puns
yeah suffer he's winning it would seem
well knight takes e6 oh pardon me knight
e6
65 d6 is a move might be
knight bit
c5 now that's like almost anything c4 a3
you take and it's a2
and you can't stop it
and rook takes e6 was on tap and mvl
actually beat dominguez
from a much worse position
okay knight
i is is it time for c5 now
it might be ali ray's uh
just reaching for his rook
g8 okay rook takes b4 can be met as you
said by 82
and nobody's stopping the runaway
all right
yeah i'm not even sure what you do here
well
e6 a2
e682 is on a board right rook takes b4
queen and rook takes b2 and you you kind
of try to play this one
because knight
kind of helps you to secure the king
yeah i mean i have no illusions
obviously lost for white exactly but at
least the game's going
and king e5 but then your rook is left
unprotected right for caffeine like f5
yeah okay
jumping right now
wow but magnus is really uh he's running
away with it yeah
he
and with all the games concluded how
many decisive games did we see this last
round um
wow it's just such a high number of
decisive games well it's the nature of
blitzmann absolutely but that's exactly
what even throw-ish positions you
continue playing with this two seconds
increment and inevitably some someone
makes a mistake right exactly we saw a
number of games here christian but
just take us through other results that
might have caught your eye well this one
in particular the one between dominguez
and mvl and i was telling you guys that
mvl won his game but from a completely
losing position and this was the case
right now his king is getting viciously
attacked check this out the queen is
already on g6 i only need the ec square
available for my queen if i manage to
give that check without exchanging the
queens then i'm just simply winning so
what he had to do at this point he
played the move king queen to h7 which
allows black back into the game the
simple rook he one would have just
stopped the game because the only move
right now you cannot just withdraw with
the queen queen to e6 will finish the
game so you have to find this very fancy
uh rook to d2 but after rook takes c3
rook takes uh d1 king c2 knight takes c3
king to b3 this is just simply
completely winning for a white but we do
have alejandro in zagreb with the world
champion magnus carlsen alejandro
magnus what a day it was for you plus
five every game decisive what clicked
i don't know really i mean i felt felt
like my play was pretty shaky throughout
most of the day
but
yeah i mean i i won a bunch of these
very like nervy time troubled
duels where nobody really knew what was
going on so
uh i guess overall you know uh
i um
while in the rapid i think i could have
scored more today i had um
uh probably scored a little more than i
should have you mentioned that in the
rapid you had a little bit of issue with
time management but it seems that now
that both sides started in time pressure
you were the one that was able to
navigate better when the seconds came
down ticking
yeah i guess navigate better is the the
operate word i i don't necessarily think
i always navigated it so well but um
it felt like i was always
uh one step a step ahead of my my
opponents in those situations but yeah
it was it was a crazy
day really i mean
um
not
one that i'm like massively proud of but
it's so they're not proud of no but it's
fine it's still it's still
pretty cool to have played no no draws
at all no draws
i don't think you've ever done this at
least not in a gct where you went a full
day without a draw no i don't think so
uh i had one day in leuven i think where
i won seven games and one draw and one
loss i think so at least uh is that
slightly better or slightly worse no i
mean that's obviously obviously a little
bit worse but um
now this was um yeah i don't
think i've ever done anything
quite like that i mean i've had days in
the world blitz like last year where i i
lost like three games but i won a bunch
as well
but i don't think i made a couple of
draws at the end
yeah it's really it's really uh
pretty pretty unusual and uh
it's not the kind of way that i pride
myself on playing but it's
i guess pretty good entertainment so i
shouldn't complain you started the day
off against jordan when forest a point
behind you immediately caught up didn't
step off the gas did you feel very
motivated to beat him in the first round
yeah i mean i did
catch up but then i lost two games in a
row and came
in rounds three and four so didn't last
very long but
um i mean once i saw the pairing
i thought i should try and try and win
the first game
which wasn't the game wasn't great but i
was always like trying to keep a lot of
pieces on the board and make him make
him think and finally he made a few
mistakes if you had to choose one thing
that you want to improve tomorrow
compared to today what would it be i
mean i hope that i will not lose like an
idiot to wesley again
well big hopes there for mangas carlson
tomorrow the world champion leader of
our tournament here at the grand chess
tour in zagreb one day to go guys back
in the studio we'll have more interviews
with you soon
thank you alejandro everyone has their
goals miro and these are our standings
after nine rounds of play okay it's a
same familiar name on top and it's
already one and a half points the
distance between magnus carlsen and
wesley saw who finds himself on a clear
second position for the first look at
this
line score though uh
no draws seven wins two losses and
that's the plus five that
magnus and alejandro were talking about
very impressive not exactly car ijuana
where you win seven in a row but that
looks really good yeah
that that will win you tournaments
nice actually our friend alejandro is
and did in zagreb but he's not ready yet
that's quite this was a very exciting
day i have to say always blitz is so
exciting right i know and
now let's go uh to zagreb and see what
wesley has to say if he can beat magnus
or not tomorrow
american superstar wesley saw you had a
nice day today came back
and you're not in second place how's it
feel yeah you're so kind i mean
i usually do
decently in blips like plus one plus two
last three at the most so i mean
plus two is okay i guess i'm pretty
disappointed with my crucial game
against uh jordan because also i was
playing a risk-free position
and just missing eight in the end and
blundered but uh
um but speaking of crucial games i mean
you beat you beat magnus
yeah yeah that's true i beat him also in
norway with black uh generally oh in
that game he played one a4 in the blitz
i mean it doesn't matter what he plays
you still beat him yeah i mean uh once
magnus gets going it's hard for him to
it's hard to stop him so that kind of
slowed him down a bit but uh not very
long i knew he was gonna play very
ambitiously against me
and uh
yeah somehow he said he just
made mistakes but uh
yeah overall i think pretty a pretty
solid day for me i didn't have much
problems with my black openings actually
you come up with some cool ideas
including the spanish with h6 97
destroying your pawn structure do you
feel comfortable revealing novelties
during blitz thank you yeah um
well
i
try to play what i know for blitz i
don't like playing i try to avoid
playing new openings new lines which
requires a lot of memorization try to
save them for classical
like most of the openings i play today
are openings i've already played with
countless times so i feel
very comfortable know one e45 all the
time and basically just
it's important to play what you know the
best um for a fast time control
especially yeah i want to have points
away from magnus carlsen what's it gonna
take for you to catch him tomorrow
uh well there are a lot of
players
trying to catch him and not only me but
also well you're the one in second place
though
am i clear second yes sir
yeah somehow the results outside is not
always updated but uh
i mean yeah it's very hard to catch
magnus he's the number one player
i was hoping that he wouldn't get going
i in the rapid it seems like he wasn't
really playing his best like he lost the
shack and he wasn't
he missed a lot of chances against me
and linear but uh winning five in a row
and blitz
i guess someone just has to start
winning game after game like ian also at
some point they almost started winning
game after game yeah it seems like he's
bouncing back in the tournament after a
mediocre rapid yeah i think it's very
well monumental it it's it blitz is
about rhythm so once you win a game or
two you can easily win a lot of games
like in norway i won four or five games
in a row in blitz is that the plan
tomorrow
yeah if you win one game and then you
win the second one then usually
it flows right yeah then it flows but uh
yeah i mean someone has to have to win a
lot of games if they want to catch uh
magnus probably someone has to
catch on on fire well let's hope that
it's you wesley so he is currently one
point and a half away from magnus
carlsen i know that he's going to be
trying his best for first place tomorrow
guys here from zagre we have wesley so
we'll have jordan very soon no pressure
no pressure
one and a half point yep and magnus
reclaiming the world number one by blitz
this last round win
will cement his position
newly minted position as the world's
number one blitz player impressive
performance and
i don't know if we have a line score for
wesley but
uh
he had a good performance he scored five
and a half yeah he was right very very
solid up to the moment that he lost to
one forest right exactly that was the
game that he mentioned in the interview
that that was the one that really
made him soar actually uh
and christian
your thoughts of
this first day of blitz i mean just an
incredible day but exactly what i
expected from magnus i expected him to
come guns blazing and this one because i
felt his energy in the last rounds of
rapid he was picking up the pace and
this is exactly what he's showing right
now now he must have been worried after
those uh two losses that could have
easily tipped the scales and get him on
tilt he stayed composed and after that
came back and won five games you know
just simply impressive i'm also
impressed with the way jordan is
handling himself sure he lost a couple
of games but he's still within
contention and it's not easy against
this top level player so he's definitely
showing some good chess and a lot of
improvement but we do have alejandro in
zagreb with a jordan van forest
jordan -1 in the blitz today but you're
in third place mixed feelings no no i'm
actually quite satisfied with my blessed
score not not mixed feelings at all um
four out of nine is for me an excellent
scorer in the blitz so i cannot complain
i do think i had a lot of luck in my
games to get to this score so
uh you know i'm just happy uh with the
with 409. you want some crucial games in
today in today's rounds take us through
some of your favorite moments of the day
um well my luckiest moment i remembered
it was against maxine for sure i mean i
didn't
have any chance of winning and suddenly
i i won the game out of out of nowhere
and then like all the games are kind of
a blur so i'm just trying to recollect
um
oh i think i beat even savage in a kind
of nice game so that's about it and then
the games i lost i think i all lost them
quite deservedly so no complaints about
these games as well it sounds like
you're satisfied with 409 but you're
gonna need better than that to keep your
third place what what's gonna have to
change
yeah i just hope that maybe the guys
behind me will slow down a bit but uh no
i mean i should i mean i should try to
gain some points uh to keep third place
of course um
but uh it's not gonna be very hard so i
just try to take it one game at a time
and i'll see where i end up i guess miro
in the studio thought that every player
that says that they're a bad blitzer is
lying
are you just being falsely modest or
i mean i i'm comparing myself to these
blitz monsters i don't think i'm a good
blitz player like
um i would beat most people's but these
guys are just like on another level i
would say they're just so sharp and
so insanely good it's just
it's just very hard to play against them
and to score any points at all well they
can't be in that much of another level
you're currently in a third place and
hopefully tomorrow you improve that a
little bit i'll try you know i mean i
mean i'm just gonna try to maintain
third for now and uh see where it goes
tomorrow morning playing or tomorrow
first game against magnus is very nice
of course just to play against magnus in
the first round so looking forward to
that game and then we'll see how it goes
after that jordan van gogh is here in
third place in zagreb and tomorrow he's
going to try to take down magnus carlsen
and reclaim even a higher score guys
back to the studio
thank you uh alejandro
four out of nine he says it's okay but
is he
again falsely modest or is he being i
don't know maybe maybe fairly modern
maybe fairly modest like
christian your thoughts no absolutely
again he's showing a great chess in my
opinion he came into this event his
rating is 2600 in blitz i checked him
out he didn't even make it to our
graphic or who of who the best uh bliss
players are in this tournament so uh
definitely 2600 playing against 2800
level players he's gaining a lot of
rating he's only minus one i think
that's a very respectable score and uh
going into the last round he's still
within contention and uh guys in zagreb
final thoughts about today's games
christian i have to tell you the
atmosphere has been electric the
auditorium has been packed people are
applauding after every round there's
autograph sessions after every round
despite the fact that we have a blitz
tournament it's just been crazy and to
see magnus in such a bloody day not a
single draw for the world champion for
me as a spectator here as a commentator
it's been amazing anastasia what do you
think i absolutely agree with you again
he's making the headlines here and i
think it's also maybe also because he
went to gym today and he published this
photo from g maybe he feels strong today
i've been stronger than before
absolutely he actually went to play
paddle with a bunch of people in the
morning and i know that when he gets
that exercise in i don't know what it is
about him but he just gets in the mood
to play some chess and when the world
champion is in shape it's just a
spectacle for all of us yeah i think
actually we have everything what is
needed for the tournament we have world
champion now in a good shape we have
wesley so chasing him and we also have
like a dark horse of the tournament um
you're in one forest who is you know
nearby you know trying still to make
some news so i think it's it's it's
really cool and also we have alejandro
who is also in a very very good booth
today
and really
here i'm gonna put you on the spot
what is the chance percentage chance
that anybody catches magnus crossing
tomorrow i don't know i bet for wesley
saw so i'm really hoping he will do
something tomorrow nine rounds of blitz
left in zagreb my horse's maxima
sherlock rap i don't think he's doing
all that amazing just yet but perhaps a
little search we know that he's great at
blitz guys this is gonna be amazing one
more day in zagreb before we crown the
champion of the third leg of the gct
we're gonna have to wait for tomorrow's
games thank you alejandra thank you
anastasia and once again here are our
standings going into
tomorrow our final rounds of blitz miro
the world champion yes the world
champion is leading wesley saw finds
himself with a clear second right and
one for rest just half a point behind
wesley so
young nepo
with six and a half out of nine
fourth position
linear five and a half in blitz along
with wesley so
and uh everything to play for it feels
like but i didn't inform magnus carlson
that's tough that's tough yeah that's
thank you all uh for joining us and
sharing your weekend come tomorrow same
time same no not same time
for the year that's right
or tomorrow
and
we'll see you all tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you